and we're live the the show the show
shall begin and I've never been more
nervous and more excited as this how
everyone's first time feels like this is
my ever first three-way chess call and I
know I probably that's probably not the
first for either of you but we're here
to settle a feud because because things
got real and went down on social media a
few months ago and does either of you
have anything to say before I get the
fans pumped up for this for this show
well I would cheap and you started this
you know I'm just responding and to to
you know your video but it should be fun
it should be fun especially when I crush
you that that would be fun but here's
the [ __ ] thing already
okay I lost the bet I lost the bet I had
a bet you know you don't realize I'm the
one who bet Danny so I had a piece of
that so I want to win the first bet I
wonder with the trash-talking I want to
win the chess that's right make Magnus
look like a baby I don't think he won by
enough so we have to make that score
even bigger that's right more than a big
pointy it's like a big baby I'm the
biggest of the big favorites I am I
gotta be honest guys are you eating
sorry excuse me but before we get going
I did actually see Ben that you gave a
massive shout-out on Twitter and
Facebook to get all your supporters to
come watch you live off you [ __ ]
why'd you see how many are there let's
see oh yeah yeah did did it go well
oh well actually they can't watch from
this room because of our setup they're
in another room and they're not allowed
to leave we locked them in okay okay as
we're learning I'm not gonna have to say
much today I'm really just gonna be an
innocent bystander with the rest of you
that's great for the crowd and he's not
gonna talk as much as usual that's a
real treat
so um for those of you who don't know
let me let me preface this a little more
as Simon Simon takes a swig of this beer
Ben Ben's gonna eat a little more Thai
food you know we we actually want to
remind everybody who's joining us that
today's show is a special experience
this is an adult experience parental
advisory there will be explicit content
I did lose the bet I had a bet that
Simon would drop the first f-bomb and
and been um well Ben proved me wrong but
let's let's let's play Ben's video here
so remind everybody kind of how this all
got started
that's my evil twin I'm innocent okay h4
put in an H and then if you're a fan of
that who's that a horrible GM he's like
twenty one hundred the horrible GM is
like 2,100
[Music]
he's the ginger GM ah so that's where it
all went down Simon can't even remember
his name after he insults him but I'm
sorry Ben can't but then but then Simon
you know Simon did what anybody would do
completely overreact on social media
that's what everybody does they
completely overreact on social with
anything that's what it's there for
and and then things got crazy but you
know what we wanted to do here for the
fans guys is is not just not just let
you guys settle this feud on the board
but we wanted to help them learn a
little bit about who you are because the
honest truth is as much as you guys were
insulted by the insults to each other
most the world could give a bleep and
they don't even know who you guys are so
we put together a quick list that you
guys didn't know about we wanted to let
the world in on some of both of your
career highlights and lowlights so we're
gonna start with Ben can I show them so
a true career highlight for Ben what he
was the first-ever GM in residence at
the Chess Club and scholastic Center in
st. Louis
the rumor is he's no longer welcome in
the city but he is but he was the
first-ever GM in residence he claims to
have beaten Anand in blitz he's been
telling me that story since since I was
little
didn't you say that Ben you beat
anonymous actually I told you that story
when you were
diapers at your mother's teat I think it
was five years he then says solid a lot
that's a career highlight for Ben oh
yeah so been solid he he was the world's
strongest I am for a long time at least
he was considered that and then of
course one of his career highlights is
that he has a losing record versus me
over the board yours truly is a losing I
mean obviously having a losing record
again to me is the truth hurts the truth
earns yeah yes Simon assignments career
highlights are a little bit fewer yeah
I'm he did beat gelfand in a Dutch is
this true Simon you beat Galvin in a
Dutch one time I think one day oh it's a
it's indeed yeah right
you also have an English accent that
must be that highlight that's a
highlight if I'm well they had a need
for Pena fax lights over here this is
the yeah so no highlights for Simon he
also thing and then another highlight
for you Simon is that you name all your
pods I think and I have to say if the
b-pawn does some damage here are we
gonna call it Ben you know what we might
have to spit every time I move it we see
so let's go onto the lowlights Ben's
lowlights include he's now the world's
oldest GM and also took him the longest
to become a GM 20 years 20 years Danny
you didn't you don't understand my plan
if any years to become an ion right at I
am at 20 20 years to become a GM and
then at the age 60 world champion you
know what your own steady wins the race
at least you're on a career path another
highlight another low-light of Ben's
careers he tells a lot of bad jokes kind
of like that laugher he just delivered
and another again another low-light is
he has a losing record against Danny so
I I rot eclis that one makes both the
highlights and the lowlights list Simon
your low lights are a little bit a
little bit of a longer list than your
highlights were so is there any bias
this guy on it I don't know why it's
just when we when the team came together
we were brainstorming things that are
good and bad about both you we just had
more about in fact there were several
things about you Simon that we didn't
even make this list because you know
awesome stories and exactly because of
she'll post tournament stories now Danny
if I may interrupt one of the highlights
of his career as far as I'm concerned
was a story I heard regarding Simon in
Hikaru okay to me that's the highlight
of the career yeah exactly in fact we
actually incorrectly
we didn't list that one only for uh for
I don't know why we didn't but yeah
there's I agreed with you that one of my
teammates suggested that was a low-light
and I suggest that it was a highlight
exactly we're friends now that's what
counts
well okay so lowlights for you Simon one
of them is the most obvious you're known
for your hair than you are for your
chess play you branded yourself as the
ginger GM you know I don't know that
most people as Ben said he can only
remember that you were the ginger GM
didn't even know your name hey man at
least I've got some hair you know I
still which is flowing Amish with you
guys that but okay yeah we're coming up
you're better better at drinking
particularly wine than you are playing
chess is that low no thing that's a
let's yeah exactly I don't know I don't
know maybe it basically we could have
listed that at the highlight okay the
rumor is you're not welcome in numerous
casinos this is unconfirmed but you have
been you have note you have been
prohibited from from entering numerous
casinos I am on a couple of lists I'll
leave it at that I argued for this one
to be a highlight as well but you've
only spent seven hours total on US soil
and six of them were in a Detroit
holding cell I know it might be Trump I
don't know it just might be my visa one
of the most ironic things about that is
Ben Feingold is from Detroit that's
where I'm from
that's all honestly I'd even think about
that but that makes this whole thing
spookiness suspicious and then once
again once again both a high light in a
low light is that you named all your
pawns so so there you have it everybody
that's um that's who we're dealing with
today we're dealing with you I was just
[ __ ] amazing
you're a great host over there I feel
like a school child before this language
at the moment I know well you should
well we've already got about thirty five
hundred people here and they don't want
to hear any more of this of these
shenanigans they want to they want to
get the show on the road so
we're gonna let you guys face off now
I'm gonna take a back seat fans no
longer have to look at my ugly mug and
as soon as these games start everybody
the trash talk is on the only rules are
that there are no rules this is a Fight
Club today I expect it to be a dirty
match and any of you have any last words
before I start the clock and in the
games begin
good luck kind sir you'll need it
Chiz I'll take it um I'm already having
a couple of days just to give you a
chance pin all right all right look it's
pretty weak today well let's um let's do
it everybody let's do it team let's get
these games on the road and let's let
the that the commentary begin this is um
oh yeah I teamed fine gold let's go you
know I didn't decide who gets to be
white or black of you I don't really
care who's white or black who wants
white that's am i cute given the head
stars out in the me you know that's true
Ben gets white let's do it all right
let's see how does chess work the pointy
guy with the stick yeah the pointy guy
with this thing examine your way fans
we're gonna talk a little more about the
feud here between these guys Simon
Williams spending a whole bunch of prep
we're gonna talk about his his
preparation tegra talk about food oh the
feud the food exactly know where Ben Ben
you old plenty of time for food get your
mind out on the plate
let's go ahead and start yeah go me and
uh and here we go bright ting naughty
hell no that's higher than I thought it
was what the hell you know no offense
but you really cheered get 2295 it takes
one to know one I have to know what a
low rating is first oh man I mean oh I
see you're very exciting player took
back they told me you would sacrifice
material I thought you're gonna play
like Knights decent I can see this is
gonna be a lot of fun with your exciting
style of chess but it's it's the boring
world of niels bohr over here I put the
one thing I learned all these Pat
sasori's lower rates of play so 2200 and
below
they always play the exchange French
because they don't know anything else so
you're doing well man you're doing well
and they always be they cheap on to
quickly understanding and then they give
a pat to Caesar check this is just silly
goose always check I can't believe it
wanna see how did you get such a fright
[Laughter]
I only carry one square that was my
problem only one square so I like to
bishops so exchange French it's gonna be
one of those days is it yes I have to
take out like two bishops I haven't hung
a piece yet I can't believe it you tame
well Ben you're doing well yeah thank
you okay complimentary did I lose on
time yet I'm so old the time control
remind everybody you can see it there 5
to blitz to start this is just like a
speech as championship but just much
much worse chess is gonna be pleased
this looks like the safest let's go here
ok well let's make you interesting you
know we can we can't we call me ginger
style here ok are you gonna push Harry
before me no you're gonna push here
alright oh my words wait can I can I
have black here he's cheating on you Ben
I mean Harry's cheating on you let's see
what let's do a jenshaw hottie what a
knife is attention hardy it's a rover
the rover okay see that I win you out
not yet do I have to retreat like a
Frenchman Wow
I wouldn't expect anything less you know
alright let's retreat and then I'll
reach what I wanna see wait wait did you
get you Jam Title III son away in the
mill it was so he actually got his GM
title also playing me also playing Danny
runs yeah that was one of my lowlights
yeah it definitely it didn't make the
low light list but the two bishops the
two bishops
two knights - nice - good it's you know
this is still theory yeah this is this
is nimzowitsch son of a [ __ ]
Moochie opening books here
I can understand understand where you
got your writing from now this is still
theory well they don't need more bed to
make this a challenge all right let's go
one of the best parts about that draw
that Ben Ben had against me they got the
title was that it wanted me to give him
a draw early in the game and I refused I
try I don't remember that I'm too old I
tried to deny him the GM title even
though a draw of hearing we're not we're
not here to listen to you try no I just
wanted to say that no wonder Rudd is oh
wait a minute I gotta play like Harry
against me I mean ah it's the only way I
could try to beat you eight it's the
only way so should I take on g6 and
blunder a rook probably but I'm too old
to blunder a rock well I'd be more rook
lose than I expected if you're a
suspicious game a typical exchange
friends very boring very boring stuff
fair yeah okay
they told me I was supposed to play
boring against you I guess I didn't
listen I'm gonna try to spice it up you
know not my strong suit
it's okay I'm left it will have to push
Ben looks like Ben's coming okay here
comes Ben although I don't know
everything loses all right let's do this
push Ben I push Harry and Ben I have the
advantage
well here we come let's just fry me oh
that's never I may see what's good let's
push him let's see these in mine all
right let's go you have to make them
weird here we go
where's Harry you've lost Henry I lost
Harry Turner okay so we can see a nice
boring exchange French we've been
fortunate I lost Harry playing some very
suspicious moves and that's that's how I
play extremely I don't like anything
that's that catchphrase you lose Ben
I've heard suspicious
well it's one of my suspicious
catchphrases all right maybe let's take
who knows okay let's let's see what
happened is it time to sacrifice you can
you can you can blunder on been
expecting that I would wonder what I'm
already losing all right let's let's
sacrifice I wouldn't expect it might
work let's go anything less you know but
this rating I'm playing well that's the
highest ring I've ever had
what's the problem what is this what is
this it's chess this is how we play in
the u.s. we sack exchange consume for
wonder you know what I just realized
fans is I can actually mute myself its
nicest thing I don't like it
the issue is we're gonna be talking
right now you can hear me man pretty
they can so I can give a pin for a
position I'll try to do it when they're
quiet I take this guy won't take back I
can't believe you sacrificing you swap
Queens off sacrifices and exchanges
Queens let me know if you want some
unbelievable yeah I don't like anything
unbelievable sacrifice in exchange
Queens it's something okay yeah well you
know you keep doing that sir okay
we'll see what happens probably nothing
good I might do it on time
not good I always play King one okay I'm
gonna have to ignore that this time and
maybe maybe this is you know you've
managed to you managed to treat me
somewhat yeah I did I don't know it's
possible we can I have black okay
I'll be quite cool if we could swap
colors a stages a new rule in the in the
chess here it doesn't look like an
exchange French looks like chess960 so
what is happening I think theory
so swindling some swindling bang old
theory yeah
Simon's worried if I quiet he's too
interested in the game of dishes and he
has his Quietus of hurt Danny okay Ben
we even you've managed to somehow
swindle some chunks is always pretty
quiet all right let's go all the way
over here gotta go somewhere
but it looks like Simon's coordinated
the worst out of it cuz this a pawn is
just gonna come forward he can play
Knight to before and hit the seat you
still losing on time ok I got him where
I want him be aware as an engineer we're
not
advice for any of them well they're all
right I'll take this that seemed like a
good move light before that was I think
Rick c7 was better we see senator yeah
now I'm pushing all my points Rufus and
doofus go you've got a poor Ben's coming
it's just typical depends gonna decide
the day in this first wow this is this
is online chess he can't make an illegal
move darn that's wrong so are you gonna
play the exchange French every single
game every game even when you don't play
you six this is bad gonna do it I'm
gonna have to fix a house too okay I
mean I think I think a pawn is probably
not enough you I think you probably but
I would all there you forgot I think
generally yeah that's wrong it's you
know a pawn is maybe it's got nothing
all right let's take okay let's take run
away run what do I have no time at all
okay good nice the time I think we get
loads of time extras a lot of this
that's true check let's see you don't
you don't want to be there right get out
of there fishing me alive
okay go Ben team fine gold it looks like
you've got me in the first one Ben you
haven't seen my technique pretty
suspicious
okay c4 is explosive let's go there okay
always play the explosive move you have
to move up in the world let's see you
finish me off then just to make sure
that rating is not your real racing
gotta move up okay I can't I can't have
him check me over that would be scary
twenty-two twenty-two ninety-five may
struggle at this very very that's true a
GM should put this in the back on that I
will struggle it's true
okay get out of there always check it
maybe check okay so you go then
you can take them thank you see I'm not
sure if he's being sarcastic or not
don't I you know I don't know I can't
tell I think yeah am I losing yet no I
think you got this one do you think I
got it Wow
I think you got this one no come on
let's just assess your tactics check
nicely done Ben thank you nicely done I
won again well look at my rating I don't
know if you got over 2,300 now Wow I'm
the least 2,300 minimum you guys that
was great oh hey we need some engines
I want to play h5 @ h5 the con con come
on Harry's my game with ginger head
start neck okay I'll play I'll play in
no wait a minute which one of us is 2200
Grandmaster I'm getting confused here
now your rate has gone up blimmin Hank
yeah I haven't played a lot of blitz
game now yeah okay I see I see
I'm very because I wasn't a true W at
you and using some hustling techniques
already I'm an old man I'm confused
all right why we final push Harry also I
just can't push him this far you have to
admit I did push Harry a lot last game i
learned from my betters you did let's
see so we're gonna develop normally
they've got hurry up the board
let's see first games and I guess this
idea Benz is literally just the swap
everything off players though old as he
possibly can the last game we try to go
up is spice and so I think this is how
we got to play against you Ben yeah
we've got a spice up we'll go to the
spice Cup that's where I got my GM title
from DNA okay what's this thing what's
attack isn't I he might not see it
possible is this this is how you use the
white pieces
what's going on wait aren't I black oh
you're talking about yourself I think so
we push we push it okay yourself I can't
figure out collective action this this
Harry Combes can be a winner oh yeah
okay come on Ben let's take everything
that's it oh you see it ending
well not yet I want to develop a
peaceful okay all right so how has never
been good to me
oh yeah he's dead darn how do we get the
action Wow I finally understood what I
mean by British GM I never understood it
before even though I kept saying it but
now I understand you know it's all
coming to me now well this this should
be careful here should be a little bit
careful to be a little bit careful
yeah I think Harry stone is one charge
of the most went here Wow I mean Livie I
don't come on Ben show it to me okay
that's that's what she said okay let's
go here the ex the future ex-wife
exactly just as I said
good timing you might not get me you got
your crowd there yet Ben oh yeah that's
a huge crowd huge guy I just talked to
Bernie Sanders you said it was huge
okay I'm gonna push David what do you
call the deep one I forgot what's he
called cooling David trouble trouble in
Miami there's trouble in the hood in
this position where somebody said I
watch a drink already
well I wanted to even the playing field
but you know there was evening it it
might be a little too it was doing this
this is looking more okay let's take he
might not take back come on I've been
okay now if my students are watching
turn away turn away if you're my student
you can play a six never play of six oh
my god how can you it I highlighted it
before you the worst
I'm the worst of the worst I'm worse
than Danny if that's possible with
Caliban you should have won this
position by now can you just think about
amantha missionary now I might sacrifice
the exchange again I'm thinking about it
I figure most II you must you said so
always listen to your opponent always
helps let's play Bishop g4 just in case
it's a good move I'm guessing all your
moves by highlighting before you do it
are yeah how do I see that somehow
somebody tell them you can't see my
moves Donny your moves your moves or
none it wouldn't be healthy
Danny keep it down all these people here
they're very noisy I know you've got a
big support there yeah thank you
yeah they're always put them in track so
this is looking a little bit a little
bit suspicious the first two games
change things a little bit so when you
sacrifice the exchange both gamers and I
move my H pawn and now you take my ring
down there so okay so now our exchange
for instance I predicted King III in the
night okay let's do it now we got to
start playing so be free from the fridge
yeah doesn't matter whichever one yeah
okay what's that Thai food you have an
earlier on yeah I had to tie one on like
you yeah and what time is it over there
it's it's time to beat Harry hey guys
I'm just gonna go answer some email and
stay on for a while you guys just do
your thing you're doing great
all right we're great okay so let's do
it now we could trash talk about the
event a little too no head stop so now
it's pretty changed or c4 is explosive
let's play that explosive move c4
it's a move let's see something it's
time man you know explosions over here
although you're from Britain that's even
one we have some explosions yeah okay
right I prepared for this match many
many years ago I was married in Hastings
in 1989 so I got this match who did you
marry nice things and how can I remember
I don't know somebody whoever was there
let's see first come first serve all
right let's develop a Pete now how come
here he's still on h7 what's happening
here
well gonna have to try what's that time
go to Harry here let's see it's normal
chess playing now then all right let's
go nice control of the center you could
be free okay I always have the player
well is it's on to comfy now I don't
want to say anything nice because you
know it's the trash-talking match but
you are doing better than I thought you
would be doing very good I mean I
thought it'd be like oh we have to give
you a little a little a little push of
the stock don't be like 0 for I didn't
think it would be 0 to buy now I'm very
impressed
all right let's let's attack his night
he might not see it
so right what's attack let's see drive
more time yet ah the first time in the
match I have more time
goodnight ef4 I didn't see that thank
you
yeah but that's okay I'm already cold
enough as it is alright whose turn is it
here let's see this iced tea better be
hardened up here we got a Long Island
this iced tea up uh-oh I don't like our
office this is gonna be painful you know
I didn't realize how hard it was gonna
be listening to to to that monotone
further yeah this is the thing that's
really already grating on me let's take
this you might not take we're gonna have
to think of a way to overcome this
monotone so let's see we're doing here
what's going nice boring I still see
here on HSN very confused with the skin
Harry's still on each seven right time
to get going come on let's push him over
for them don't do that that's a good
move
you must be really confused now okay
let's reach feet like a Frenchman always
retreat and then I can reach me I guess
it's the same you got the same sayings
for the whole time huh that's correct
the same things do they have a change no
except I have a real color but now but
after and how can we just put you on
repeat is this how this works always
repeat it that's just repeat just repeat
cuz this is gonna be the same same same
stuff yeah why do I have less time it's
going on here okay oh you go what's it
like retreat like a Frenchman yeah
that's true true always
yeah especially when I've wonder it I
fought the true strength will come for
at some stage yeah okay I can see this
happening
let's see rookie 3 Queen c2 I'll just
give the exchange who needs rooks I'm
playing the ginger GM so well take you a
little friend that if I always have less
time I'm gonna win this match so
was your magical I figured it all out
you saw this in advance that's right
okay because someone it's a sacrifice of
course the guy keeps playing good news
that's not I had a dossier on you they
said he never plays good wounds so did
you did a lot of print for the mash man
I did a lot of prep let's run a prep
yeah yeah it felt that I shot pool talk
to your girlfriend before the match and
she said you were really nice and that
she thought I was the favorite and I
suppose come out and so was it true
about your wife is she as she should be
she's betting on you she has a large
wager okay and if I thought she's gonna
divorce you know well that's
irrespective of the match but yeah okay
I guess back back to e4 alright never
going back
that's what I told all my wives never
going back right yeah well okay then I
really need too much about this alright
we just play some Usha the material this
place the Moose give you give me some
chops I think I better retreat any son
Sean sir
okay let's retreat again ah oh you're
gonna say like a Frenchman no this is a
lot of new things you have some other
ones okay I want to trade colors again
always has more time had a beard longer
than I had got everything let's see is
it my it's my favorite thing to do try
to trade Queens I can try you can try
you can try to aim the same blunder
twice I can drive it away but this time
I might yeah you might get away okay
come on it needed then I lose the
endgame that's better
alright one sacrifice the exchange this
time not this time well this looks awful
it's a good thing I'm playing ginger GM
otherwise I'd be in trouble so there
that's not fair
well he's threatening everything good
play pin well I think you ought to up
though thank you I think you're handling
the stuff whatever I kind of feel your
energy levels might lag
at some point I can feel you're gonna
you're gonna run out of steam in you or
run out of gas maybe maybe he won't see
the ships attacked I'm in here for the
long run
I know for you it's probably I'm going
for this energy levels I just feel your
energy might run out later on as imagine
let's see okay I have a good one
structure you're playing this game you
play very impressively thank you yeah
this is my best game so okay so here we
are
go Ben team Ben you keep saying that and
I hate I hear the massive crowds that
your chess Center a shouting behind you
as well so it doesn't look so good
you have a lot of people at your chest
Senate been tiny funds of people be okay
is it just a bit early over there I only
early but if it was later to be the same
number
Thursday stuff over here we have a lot
of traffic
let's see my turn not a try okay Rick g1
hangs my rooks I still almost did it
almost was considering it this doesn't
look as nice as the other gammas
shooting alright so I have to make that
is much better than he was the first two
games he's tricked me you'll coming in
there should play faster but I could
play worse let's see my turn Harry I'm
so confused
Harry hasn't moved at all I wasn't
expecting this man people are can't
believe they're watching to this they
could be watching Magnus all right let's
go this is like watching to to kind of
Magnus players playing through shawnee
yeah to some things it is but don't call
me Shirley
yeah okay right so am i winning yet for
surviving am i winning somehow surviving
somehow can I return is it okay play in
the center that's the thing with my
tournament
play in the middle there
he pushed Harry darn I didn't think that
was gonna happen
he pushed here okay I'm gonna push let's
see
what's her name what's a this guy's
playing too good this isn't fair
okay let's see it I have no time
I think offs today oh that second game
I'd say Harry let me down quite badly
good a second alright gotta keep
retreating keep retreating always
retreat you're playing very you just
you're just not doing anything which is
that good you're just not doing anything
you're not moving anything is not good
how come you don't try and do anything
yeah if you were as good as me you'd
know how bad my position is Wow what I'm
not doing anything
should I still retreats always retreat
just keep going backwards man yeah this
is the only way you can I think I can do
any style that mean you take me out
later comply it's hard to disagree oh I
didn't retreat so that was bad
sure you just going back was a force
like huh that's what she said yeah no
you guys not a repeat another epi Casino
lady played h5 I can't believe it he
moved Harry's can't believe okay good
play the venue you playing this is a
nice impressive game this gives me Harry
over here this gives me a lot of hope
now this isn't good I have no time the
repetitions bed I only have one hope
let's see let's Queen over here I'll
make a queen that's my whole life good
play that's my hope if I make a queen
I'll go now it's doing well let's see
that I queen yet I guess if I trade I
want Queen 44 seconds we have increment
or something good play that there it's
nice nice nice nice positional play can
you check me yourself so how can you do
it can try yeah good
there's a looking good here I was
rooting for me this is terrible I'm
higher rated than you now when I lose
this scam I'll be like everybody
watching a horrible horrible okay get
out get out get out ulch you know ok
back pushing me back now what changing
my mind yeah I think the only way you're
gonna win is if I do something stupid so
do something stupid
well specialty I mean at the moment
you're just going backwards and forwards
don't understand I can still go
backwards you can still go backwards the
main is look I'm gonna go backwards next
move to Boston I might try some tactics
actually I'm trying you're trying to
achieve here oh my god yeah good good in
gameplay I can see for yourself thank
you I'm trying not trying too hard
let's see now what do I do lose on time
wow this position is really bad ok maybe
I can win now ok
somebody blindfold them it's my only
hope so ok let's activate Erie counts
that's with an R how do you activate
something with an R let's see I'll put
them in check
ok and then let's come down here and
then I'm active now I'm the favorite
right I know what's your time it's like
20 seconds it's just a nice sexy fun all
the time
that's nice activity banal games so well
done for that congratulations not a lot
of time here this is you know I'm a
little slow little slow on the draw here
just let's see retreat yeah and I said I
think this is good this is a good game
you're playing thank you
that's the best nice yeah thank you I
went forward that's not my specialty now
I'm confused 18 seconds it's hard to
trash-talk with 18 seconds if somebody
has to do it
not gonna be me come on bad you have an
active king he has nationals
I don't fitness any need for trashes
organized position position plays itself
he has no chance it's nice to give you a
little a little sort of less than there
let's go I have good drunk Jenkins like
a plate what good night doesn't be the
rook yeah this is a yeah you've caught
it you can't have been schooled here
mind my film this is this is a yes I'm
doing I'm doing well I'm doing well this
is a schooling here no no this is good
yeah
this is good this is good good chances
for me very good chances all right I got
been I got been going you go up in there
you go then okay and then let's go here
for some reason sure why exactly go Ben
yay I promoted Ben go then this isn't
working out too good you lost it longer
not full then go back this was kind of
go Ben I missed this one yeah you need
to see that move I miss this once why oh
I missed that nice move
oh here it looks like still meet is
inevitable Chi Chi Chi guys know how to
resign I mean we don't know did you not
teach this to your pupils no we told
them never resigned is this you trying
to like yeah I actually don't know how
the reason I mean wait I should ask you
how to resign you're the expert well Ben
I think that was just a schooling there
you know a little bit fun in the first
few games I think the little bit of club
you were feeling bad sorry I lied to
watch you win again yeah I think I think
you just you've got completely schooled
there that was my same gameplay I mean I
can understand now why your title was
such an old age that's right forty years
until 40 I found the resign button it
took me two minutes okay that's rated
good stuff
Wow only only in your imagination
I'm it's a pretty decline that's too bad
okay where's h4 that's why wait
Harry's had his fun today what's a
little bit of Rage Against you're gonna
have fun but now I'm ready are you
playing the English defense is this the
name of this I don't know maybe
yeah Bishop III I faced that before
you're an all-state yeah so to another
schooling now is okay one up you one up
my head I'm too old I don't remember
so still theory still fairy what's time
it's still very still fairy come on Ben
put on your pipe and smoke it Sun it
straight up yeah it's good you're gonna
get up your bottom now Ben which maybe
you enjoy I don't know there's quite a
thought some stories I believe those
people hear something
I believe she's told some stories this
is a phrasing one choice and that's the
bad part what is this this doesn't look
good alright nothing the third-ranked I
should be okay you know you're playing
King f8 very good yeah
Magnus probably this opening although he
did make a large wager on you darn those
turns at my turn they're the barren she
is now coming in okay alright so give
Sun another beer come on actually I'm
proved with bass you know is it bit it's
a bit like you and food I feel you know
after after every meal
the elo goes up a little bit a little
bit more similar thing here yeah you're
causing a bit of mischief though aren't
you I'm trying to get a little bit of a
mischief-maker here now if I play King
GA is it like chess960 I'll castle for
me let's count one let's see if you can
survive achieve there right now you can
take a pawn their fee if you say wish
okay I'll take your bishop well he moves
it away that's not good now you can call
so just just to give you some hints that
you get along the King can go to a chair
darn
let's see yeah
is it my turn and you always have to say
something I mean do you ever have like a
little moment way you just take a breath
he is nice attacked I mean you have to
say saying something something okay
thanks thanks for something yeah the
Beatles will be proud of me so okay take
the pawn is suggested by my opponent
take a ball and have a port or meter you
got to have the port right well done
Terra but you are to one up so you know
we got her we got to give you a little
bit of respect for giving that little
head start very little respect
yeah well not I mean now you're playing
as I as I imagined you not much
understanding but a bit tricky bit
tricky at times attack you know yeah
typical idea that I see there you know I
again this is the kind of move I'd
expect moving the King into the middle
of the board in a dangerous position
waiting for something and yeah I mean
it's all pretty solid you're appoint up
your opponent though it's good play I'm
the best let's see should I play
defensive aggressive or all three
I can't count for a while either all
right let's triple it up it's the fine
gold gun so are you gonna second see
free pen because you seem to be the
master a losing I was gonna play rugby
for rugby for okay that's a much better
move dc3 was better I can't take all
your suggestions I could get in trouble
then okay some cheating okay my turn
it is your turn I don't like this
position er you're pulling up in every
position like for some reason I'm not
sure why you'd better pessimist in a
heart yeah well you're such a fine
player much better than I expected
well only twice as many points for me
well twice as many yeah okay three yeah
okay Ben come on you were pulling up
here let's see your technique now it has
to be quite an easy spot very good yeah
I think I'm gonna have to play like
Simon again I have to do it
gonna have to do it come on I gotta do
it I mean this theory you're learning
you're letting the way and you pushed
Harry wait a minute so we're playing for
a little money and what are you can do
to money if you win
how many Harry's are here I don't
probably get chess lessons from Danny
that's yeah sure great we couldn't
afford me buddy yeah that's so you can
make that true I'll keep forgetting
you're there Danny here the fans have
enough with you guys you guys are
killing it every time I say something
they tell me they tell me to shut up and
chat so you guys are doing great okay
never play up three never never in my
worst nightmares for I'd be in a
threesome review Dan Ian and Ben stuff
of nightmares and also just the voice my
god it's just like says the Brit it's
really not it's really not what I had in
mind this is a day of entertainment to
be honest but okay okay come on
so do me a favor though guys take us
take a 30-second break before you
rematch in the next game so I can tell
you some fun stuff going on in the chat
okay as people yell at me to shut up
which is great I mean I love it you were
also yelling you could hear but I forgot
to give our sponsor some love the guys
that donated all this cash you guys are
playing for so I want to do that real
quick we should give up some love give
him some love okay thank you Ben you're
playing you're playing Roy okay nice I
am Roy's with me whenever you play like
it's a shock yeah you guys want me to
raffle something in the chat what am I
supposed to raffle I need to raffle yeah
they've got some great insults for you
guys though they're insulting each other
for you I mean they're so insulting each
of you some of these some of these are
but they're not playing just like we are
it's a hard task to employ chess but
somebody has to do it I feel this could
be I need to do a little bit of
rebuilding Ben and you know I've got the
one point for you are you are improving
and okay so it's on to turn this one
around you know what I retreated that's
not fair
I don't like that move that move looks
good I'm against it
oh I don't like that I don't as per
usual
all right let's do it you're such a
pessimist you're skilled with it ma'am a
pessimist experience now you come back
again what we're going forward before am
I losing on targets should I should I
take you in the same thing because that
seems to be a weak point that's my weak
point okay all right let's take this guy
let's take Gary the G file Gary take him
taking on to control you Gary yeah
doesn't look that bad for me it's my
normal bed yeah they're all right I'll
take it you got it
this looks pretty good you been okay
this is looking pretty good it is yeah
this is look like one of the best
positions you got Wow okay so I should
be should be a struggle again here it's
fun to struggle life is a struggle been
especially when I'm listening to you all
day yeah exactly
it's a bloomin big struggle and it's not
gonna get any better I feel so I mean
just listen I hate to go forward I hate
to do it I hate it
the struggle is upon me I hate to go
forward Yukiko poets I'm going sideways
that's a kind of forward right it's not
exactly forward Coleman now it's just a
matter of technique it is dirty Russian
say no let's see what do I do
all right let's go over here gotta go
somewhere and I still have no time was
it my 50th year my 40th year
used to be fast used to be I could have
been a contender I used to be funny as
well yeah used to it you know
well hey how we used to be a lot of
things well what do you do rugby 5 yeah
just like I move you know it's dangerous
Wow like your life is a risk yeah that
seems like you playing dangerous over
here okay Queenie seven trip I don't
care about okay come and I don't care
about it kill me here a little this has
been a tough one
how do you always you have two three
minutes left on move forty and fifty
what's happening here and I'm playing a
bit too quick wait that move was good or
was it I have a spy Trek nicely done
thing I have a spy track okay take a
break he said which is good because
there's too much stress for me and one
old me I'm confused
I can I can use the little boy's room
okay three one oh my words write songs
have never smoked very suspicious I'm
taking that gonna break Simon keep the
keys to cancer in the box for a second I
just see back you five minutes don't
worry all right
your dad he's down he's down 3-1 so in
been stuffing his face I can't really
complain if Simon wants to take a break
and I'm gonna let the timer keep running
if he's losing the match Wow our break
that was a lot of trust for me if he's
losing the match and doesn't want to be
here that's fine right alright we have
small children here we have small
children here Wow that's not on me okay
I didn't create that environment so
there's been a lot of great comments by
the way everybody reading the chat I
can't even keep track of all the great
insults you've been throwing been in
Simon's way it's it's it's amazing but I
do want to give a quick shout out to our
sponsors because we because first of all
what maybe what people don't know is
when this whole thing went viral we had
so many people reach out to us not only
excited for the
throwing these two together but actually
actually putting money on the line so I
want to say a thank you to the first
anonymous sponsor who as you can see as
a patriotic American just wanted to
boost the prize fund to give Ben some
love and a shout-out to the to the great
chess clubs and then of course we had a
another sponsor software software to fit
calm as you can see they increased it by
another $2,000 apparently people like
you guys I have no idea why it was so
weird and you guys being the greedy the
greedy sob that you are wanted the prize
fund to be all for you and not donate
not not increase the price one for
charity so I just want to point that out
well I'm gonna I'm gonna throw night
someone prize woman but listen first of
all anyway because I'm actually gonna
open it up right now so why don't we why
don't we give the opportunity for anyone
to to donate today today what we'll do
is how you're talking any subscribers to
our twitch channel today all that money
will go to our charity the winners
charity so if anybody who subscribes to
our Channel today all of that money will
go to charity not to chest comm so I
think we can keep track of that my my
team has told me that so let's do that
let's increase the price fun for charity
because if we're putting a couple of if
a couple of trainwreck human beings like
this on television I think we want to do
a some of my my good will and good sense
of humor to ginger because he needs it
so I'm gonna be respective of the result
of the soap so instead of instead of
only giving 250 dollars to charity we're
gonna let the twitch chat come to the
rescue of humanity which I know is a
rare that's a pretty I know that's
saying a lot but the motors the
Twitter's and they they think real
highly of me anyway so I love the
insults what I mean we must we must
thank the sponsors I mean it's been
great I mean obviously okay you know
this side offers a bit of a rack and it
probably will finish as a bit of a wrap
but I think money back as well to do
some good cause is wrong well if we get
enough donations from twitch Simon you
don't have to donate any of the $1,000
you're gonna get for getting crushed by
little bit of you know American thing
going on here no no Simon I gotta be
honest with you I was hoping you would
play better chess and you have you have
just disappointed all of us so far
Wow okay early in the match all right
all right but seriously
there you go anybody who wants to donate
for this and you know and wants to show
their love for charity subscribe to our
Channel today a support support a
charity of the winner's choice so there
you go but I did want to give those
sponsors a shout out while we had a
quick break and I'll go back to to my
corner and and answer emails and let you
guys trash talk it up so anybody want to
say anything else while you have insult
you guys keep taking shots at me by the
way that's all it's a longer break no
you guys don't even you guys don't even
need a break just thought we need to
alright let's start let's rematch
rematch keep playing alright but there
you go everyone twitch
get involved let's let's get some let's
get some money raised for a charity so
these guys can feel better about
themselves and what they're doing here
if I knew how to rematch I would do it
it's there's a point there's a button
okay I believe you
rematch okay I think I've sent one map
you found the button I get it finding
these buttons how many exchanged French
as we can play and I okay to see what
you do against this what the Dutch is
good Wow 666 this little move okay going
in Benny oh he didn't play your six you
still could have played you six see a
little bit okay alright I resign yet
okay so yeah no I think I think it's
good cause for everyone to to obviously
give a little bit of money give a little
bit enough love to a charity which
charity would you give your money to Ben
if you had to pick a charity to your own
charity if I had to pick a chair if I
had to you know yeah we have a disaster
in the u.s. basically every other day so
I guess I could just give it to
everybody okay it's that we're having
tough times over here so there's I guess
American Red Cross because they help
everybody but I hate to be serious that
was terrible not we can't be serious
uncle so serious inside of you that's
must be a big hit a little bit of
seriousness out here I'm gonna lose the
trash-talking for being serious for what
series for a second we've got a batch so
I'm actually worried about this exchange
French occur in every game I was I was
not in my preparation hey I moved in a
little bit more interesting then some
exchange French every game yet not yet
okay I was losing my queen before you
were born I figure against somebody from
Briggs and God will save my queen so I
should be okay
let's see I guess I should long castle
again cuz it always works out so you
make it a bit more interesting here
you're gonna you're gonna throw Kerry at
me
yeah Kerry's coming out making air it's
coming yeah serious Kerry let's see
always play King bee one I guess
understand rules I'm confused
are you eating comfy Benz do we go a
little bit pump you're moving been well
it means it made it's bad thing to move
been going after giving you this little
little bleed and while it's for charity
so let's go here it's for sure I was
tempting you
yeah I'd like a contempt I would not
bear to resist that really I was half
kidding yeah getting free pawns I was
half kidding oh yeah okay how would you
have to kid I'd always take right here
you would yeah I think so I only do it
on three pawns free massive pawns for
the piece really how do we do okay so
I'm gonna be the one who tries to
exchange Queens now a little bit of
energy going back in this one
unfortunately I can't well probably a
good thing I can't see the chat today
cos and why my computer did break down
I'm quite probably quite glad I couldn't
see the chats at this moment in time
which I'm sure is all very positive
let's go you like endings you prove that
a while back but this this should be a
good ending I have to say you have how
many pawns you have you have an army
opposed to many pawns coming down to
board so a good CAE they're all coming
down
see if you can use them well all right
I've got Harry Harry's gonna be a queen
in this true don't want Harry use
yourself use yourself wisely what do I
do
so we're gonna have to love all Harry
dan I need to sit down it's because I do
I do it because I sacrifice sorry let's
go we've been been versus Harry
okay well I think we're both losing hmm
okay do I always have no time maybe I
should be like thinking about my mace so
yeah let's go - lets go - Harry six was
that well supposed to go that's a good
me it is well done give me give me thank
you I think
let's see they're threatening and
defending all right let's this design
it's good Harry I have to keep pushing
on I got area you said you were gonna
Queen Harry I don't think so I'm
actually one thing with all my pawns my
pawns are dropping like flies as you can
see this is pretty bad oh I'll take back
you'll take more my turn ah let's let's
move Ben go Ben alright well I still
have no time
alright move your king up because that's
what my teacher told me so move your
king up and I prefer white what I have
to say yeah I think why it's got a
little pause so it looks like you can
have for one Ben I had a little a little
bell on this one what the Freeman
Freeman it'd be my section I bet I bet
before one to start with got some
friends laughs we get for one then it
will change wow it looks like we're
getting to the right level at the moment
and things are gonna well obviously a
little bit changing to be done before
one does look very likely it's my own
time I can't even move anything here Ben
this is this is this is exactly the way
it is bets gone but for one and to win
the match is it's gonna be tough have to
say you can do it I have I have faith in
you also after this move after this move
I don't have faith in you
well it was pretty bad already there we
go so we go the fort one yay my winnings
really high I gotta pull you more often
we have now good for my reading okay
seven o'clock good so we have half an
hour left on form
wait what about our let's give you an e
for let's see how do I buy goats d4 okay
we'll play sharp cuz you like that let's
do it let's go shop give you a little
wing gambit now this little dance before
that's know you can keep things boring
for one sharp as predicted and you know
who you are who you are betting with no
no we can play some chess this is this
is all in the book okay there's a good
book it's maybe not in the good book is
in a book but maybe not the good book or
some sort some I've never seen this
before I don't know how it's possible I
don't forget is possible but he
retreated things in life are not
possible and still they Queenie - which
one's the worst it's just a position so
we've got half an hour left I think I
have to win every game I hope it's not
bug out probably every games against
four also we just just working out the
little things that and I guess in the
one minute Ben you must be favorite you
must I can't play one day even I've
played too quickly I was good at one
minute before you were born and then you
were born and a lot of things for I pull
on this we were born it was all over I'm
remembering those catchphrases yours Ben
and there they keep coming out before
you're born
I'm sure what else we get out you're
good at divorces I'm good at good too
many time it's time to time to get out
before so that's here's what else so you
get it divorces always always plan 888
always plain itha always plain i h8 okay
so now we're rolling what one of the
chatters requested that you take off
your sunglasses Ben oh those are those
are just dark circles actually exactly
okay that's too funny for Danny they
have
Danny you go bun in there Danny that
wasn't DNA that was too funny
okay I don't like this position you
don't know any position you like
mouthing yeah I got plenty of nothing
but luckily it's plenty for me well I
think you know what's in it I'll
Telegraph in it it's the porgy and bess
defense what do I do
so I certainly need to win this game
otherwise I feel the match is just
slipping away I really want to sacrifice
a bit like you plain like a bit like a
very mouthy Magnus today you know thank
you
well a very mouthy Magnus you know yeah
you know kind of Magnus who has the same
jokes time and time again drugs well
well okay but anyway last game I feel
for me looking good you know we're
getting too funky opens coming out
coming it's working we've got two full
one it's going a game plan I've written
down the score before the match if I get
that score and perfectly was it zero
zero before the match it was a full one
I'm before the match started well looks
like an equal position if I knew where
the draw button what a great looks looks
very cool it could be time for a bit of
fury action here oh oh if you have an oh
well that means I don't so it's good
okay probably probably doesn't know it's
okay yeah what's happening here I think
it damn well yeah I mean you've got a
you've got a lot of potential in your
position potential that's true you have
to say the time has passed but all my
pieces are you gonna go fer you're gonna
go free again why not you go do
something
alright b5 let's they'll give you a lot
of counter play I see it's a lot of
counter play lazy counter play so wait
for is twice as many as two I said to
the math now that's dangerous me it's my
only hope
well I don't know what's worse our trash
talking or applying well come on let's
just stay there
this is pregnant Wow this is put it in
the pipe oh good whoever is good bad or
ugly it has to be played spicy now that
looks pretty good we have to get a
little bit more spicy now we've had up
we've had our fun and games well that's
fine that's fine Akhil warm up though
all right is it good looks pretty good
is it good no it's just a move yeah it's
good it's just a move just a move good
it might be a good move it might be a
bad move it's a move you're right your
ratings go a little bit yeah you fear me
now I'm complan 2,400 below my neck well
so I straighten your bean bin I hear
it's like 24 25 17 saying it's pretty
good that's that sounds all too high a
little too high okay good but I mean
you've been up there yeah I've been
higher rated than I am now yeah okay
this is terrible this is awful okay I
mean I you know the worst I mean I can
see I can see what what am i if I can
see one of my dead friends might be
terrible
well I've seen worse I mean he told me
to let you win but I wasn't really doing
it this much God okay this is why it's
just a position c5 Wow well you know you
can see that coming to life now it's all
coming so my king so majority is gonna
win this yeah that looks revolting
that's gonna while your Bishop on b2 was
pretty good it was pretty good I'll give
you know yeah okay Bishop g2 you're
still surviving somehow you never play
f3 oh wait why do I play a3 never play
up three did you play three yeah hasta
tatak I'm gonna fall in - I don't think
so you have some spite check
yeah that's not gonna be good let's just
take that one see what your idea is so
obviously I do need to win this game I
think to have any chance but
we got to the for one we've woken up a
little bit now this is the kind of chess
we need about numbers exchange French an
age Bend that you have to play the
exchange French all the time
it might look I have to say so will it
work against say well I only play two
ones against me and I sacked all my
pieces and Castle queenside come on I
get some credit very little
how could my position be so bad how is
it possible things that bad I think I
think you're okay how is that even
possible that it was there bad I think
your positions okay looks like on nasty
tactic here I do I wish I saw it maybe
I'm not sure I'm not sure it is but
maybe you do I don't know where it is
but maybe maybe there is say maybe this
is so terrible it's possible it's
possible maybe he won't take back it's
possible he took back I have to take
this one I have no choice I guess you
saw I I can take that one but ah always
retreat master plan now becomes clear
then I see my friend I'm actually quite
join us against in this position come on
that's more like it
couldn't stay away so we've got four two
now okay fortuitous for both okay so
we're gonna we're gonna test that you're
changing my e point again let's go plays
like Magnus
this isn't good he's playing like Magnus
right it's not good right well this is
the way I play like you know you play
nice yeah finally it finally enough I've
never studied your games for some reason
believe it you know I don't know so you
so you know I've never studied your
games they've never come across my radar
yeah no idea why that is it's amazing
funny it is
you know I a lot of things that come
across my write-up and not your games
games your games never appeared on my
radar I got away
yeah it's very strange in this match I
also spent half now studying your game
spend that's really no make you feel
better no okay but come on you're for to
up you're doing well you did well I'm
fortunate enough yeah you beat me you
beat me for two I'm already lost and we
have only 20 minutes to this lefty you
can oh you're gonna obviously your big
frame for one minute I also I need to
win the next two to have a chance in the
big favorite yeah well you're big yeah
yeah yeah okay I'm not sure about and
thought yeah okay what's going on here
wow I guess you can attack me again
let's see if you get frustrated to me I
am frustrated yeah that's that's that's
a move that's move it might be a bad
move but it's a it's it's it's a move
it's a move on scared of I have to why
do you always have five minutes left
it's guys trash-talking notes is this
replay and still I'm playing fancy
quickly that's why play quicker
something are worse wait I'm higher
rated alright you're doing well I can't
lose this one can I wish I could see the
audience so I can insult them easier to
insult they're not beating me and I
don't think I'm being you by looks the
schools been either was tough last game
is one game I'm gonna have to do this
it's not me if I wanted to play you
scared me there I want to suck all my
pieces and then I can resign good plan
you can you can go for it so okay so
it's 40 I think I do need to win the
next two I need to get a little bit more
violence in the game we need to start
attacking and obviously why it's a lot
better here we're gonna see what kind of
plan Ben comes up with you know you lost
me scare me awful you're just trying to
open my position up and retreat always
retreat all Reis retreat that seems that
seems like it could run into trouble but
yeah maybe I mean I don't know maybe you
have some great plan up your sleeve here
but actually you sometimes what I wanted
a piece yeah yeah I mean obviously I'm
just waiting to see your great plan
it'll probably is
actually quite dangerous me but okay I'm
sure you miss this one I'm sure I have a
feeling you may have missed this idea
maybe yeah well your Bishop ib7 doesn't
count
so I'm actually had a pawn now so yes
yeah so that's what it is okay so that's
what let's grab it let's grab it calm
that's it so a my point Knight f4 is
that what I think so I think so okay and
then something this is actually yeah I
figured it all out yeah I know my style
sacrifice a piece my accidents actually
most of my piece that replaces are
accidents unbelievely completely you got
something here have to let you test it I
have to go here okay
and then I have to do something I guess
here yeah I don't want to do it but I
have to this is looking just to move his
kick
I believe you can blunder place and you
get away of it I'm a fine believe all
right I think you got away of it take
this a lets you know what do I do
that's the next question so fulla T so
we want it you know interesting position
I think isn't it interesting alright
let's do it let's do a rover let's do a
rook lift I like it okay for me or for
you
unlike the idea is this this is the
Jennifer idea yep okay got Fiona I got
Jennifer we got better for over here I
like him okay check maybe he won't see
it like he saw you is in check I had to
do something I would see free but I was
right I wonder Queen c3 that way I get
both of them I get fnc okay Nona and
what starts with C what it was like case
of past this easy check that but what do
you do King age 7 yeah let's get in here
you got me on defensive so you are
attacking me
I'm trying you're attacking me big gang
I'm actually moving too quick I'll never
have this problem I don't know which is
I'm very surprised about all right let's
keep going and do my favorite thing
trade Queens it's my favorite okay
better here I have a next string well
it's not me let's see that didn't work
out too well so I think you're winning
this one you should be winning here I
should this is this this looks easy it
does Wow looks easy
looks easy I mean yeah I mean bass oh
yeah I think it looks easy if you say so
good stop it's tough to me what always
have last time I ever do to deserve this
yeah okay oh I didn't see that do you
think you would die that's not very nice
yeah you know it's not very nice is this
love
yes they why you play rook there carry
the one plus tax
all right let's go here yes I'm gonna
have to break my rule that was nasty
that was that was the nasty little hit
ones nasty I'm gonna have to break my
rule I think hey breaking my rule I
don't know I still don't like this it's
too complicated it's complex they too
complicated let's see there I don't know
so confused
it's too hard to trash truck can play
good wolves can't play good blues
without trash talk this is a tough
position I have to say this is difficult
it is okay I'm gonna go for what the
hell was that American [ __ ] out I'll
take that yeah I thought it had
something I don't understand that was
not the mood to play I've easily
confused so it's okay
hmm confuse myself so tonight yeah well
I'm catching up on time I can't believe
it this is great some reason I'm sort of
hallucinating as a deep on there which
is not a good thing when you start to
loosen they've been not good okay go on
yeah
maybe the water comes in so there you've
taken this sector it hasn't gone to plan
I four is gonna win the next two four
four keep the tension on you didn't win
you and I'm still win yeah I mean I was
banking on a fall for this this was a
aiming for but it looks unlikely I have
a chance we'll see this looks like a
good one you have a good chance that
looks like a good wolf that's a good
move looks like a good credit where a
good move is is okay come on in band you
can say that one good okay let's do it
so okay let's see I'm sure you might go
see five again no that's securing me I'm
gonna almost almost okay we're gonna
have to come at you so we're gonna have
to come at you with some some random
random rubbish to get a little
aggression going I'm sure you might take
my porn all right I'll make taking the
free porn it's not good I'll take now do
you have any threats no nothing I'm just
carriers my heroes you know
so I'm just playing like hikaru cheap
ideas so maybe this is only the last
game of the this section so I think been
to have a chance against you you know
just you know we go
we go workouts we're going oh I probably
need to win this game don't I have any
chance
well if you win this so Ben I think I
think it's all you
I think it's just just to add that using
using Harry for the H file for the class
just just just friends losing this is
called the hillbilly
the one and only hillbilly apparently
yeah and okay so we've got nice you free
coming up I like it okay well if you're
gonna plan the H file
I guess I'll plan the a file very
sensible that's the only make sense
never play f3 I can't believe how
quickly I'm moving what's wrong with me
maybe I should be thinking more and
moving slower no than you always this is
this is the thing maybe three minutes
section threes are funny well let's do
that yeah I'll take it
it's a funny move funny move funny move
from the funny guy they say they say so
they say something I know someone says
that I'm sure I'm sure your wife says
that your wife must think you're funny
yeah this is still theory a thing yeah
it's still in the books yeah this is the
Carlson versus Feingold I believe I
think I beat him but I forgot my
memories not what he used to be
we beat yourself for something like this
I beat somebody yeah okay like this
position you're beating me at the moment
you know you're fired
I don't know how you doing it I mean
it's it seems like you're playing bad I
like your point you're using the metric
system
which is really weird no I think I think
is the other thing you'll play badly but
I'm playing terribly that's shocking
that we could play like that Wow yeah is
it time is it time to take you into an
ending let's the come and I know you
love them I know you love Lester Lester
okay I like Ed games okay let's let's do
it let's let's try an ending there you
go you know I can give I guess that
weakens g6 it has to be good all right
yeah this is pretty boring I like it mmm
this is a bit more boring than I like it
than a fridge isn't it okay let's see
you're attacking a pawn it's not very
nice I might as well try very nice all
right
defense okay it's good for white how do
you have five minutes left I'm I don't
know I really don't know I'm leaving far
too quick far too quick
yeah I'm trying to get an extra two
games in but okay we'll see who's never
play f6 or never playing six welcome
tell me a ruse B'nai I don't know I
don't know you'll catch phrases or play
off six yeah you don't know my
catchphrase as I never say them when you
get a hearing aid like meal nalem you'll
remember look cb4 that's that's been
that's not Harry yeah I mean I I read
only move the guy but that's that's Ben
that's my guy thing it is Ben is your
guy Harry
nobody's move there each pawn this game
is very position then again wow I've
moved been twice in a row and they're
only feels oddly anxious for it still
still in the books
you're doing well you like ending so
this should be it'll be anything good is
then games real speciality been well
used to be until this match yeah that
way I can I hang fewer pieces when it's
the young game there's very few pieces
on the board so I like that you are
still controlling me in this match you
realize that really pretty boring
position it's not as exciting so many
other ones there I better take him okay
that's very scary is here no no coming
off article coming off let's go here
that was exciting
ah as an exciting move very fair you
know that's a hot race of that one yeah
alright I'll take this guy and I can't
do very much here it's not so good well
much no I don't like anything weird be
it's the theoretical move that's that's
an open file right listen I can fall pen
nice
that's how we do is America yeah thank
you that loses that loses everything
loses it's a good thing I'm the onions
expert why so negative when you're three
points up it's right I thought I would
be doing better
I'm shocked it was so weird that you
know I mean I can't believe I'm only
three points up four points four pawns
1% rule if he doesn't know it I'm good I
think you're actually losing the plot
little bit well you thought wrong what
can I do if he knows that he knows it
how do you have four minutes left I'm
playing two quick quick this isn't fair
auntie what time okay we got to get
let's see Catherine going here c5 play
explosive explosive yeah so your goal is
to play quick and get more 5 min
occasion hmm well maybe I mean it's not
good it's not going so well at the
moment sure maybe maybe I should be
playing you know playing for them okay
what about this is this is this legal
good I don't like it this is it legal
no it's barely legal exactly barely
legal I better get over here
looks dangerous over here okay aunt eNOS
you're also going over there let's see
looks terrible I've never said that
before never you're very optimistic plan
yeah okay right mattes
nobody's little move so you're in tank
ain't gamemaster yeah is that correct
that's what I am yeah okay
right something yeah okay glad glad to
clarify yeah good good no I mean I'm
good I just was looking forth I wasn't I
wasn't sure if you're an in-game master
or not you know I'm just just now you're
sure no you know good good good good
so your speciality is the young game
disposition yeah no time maybe maybe you
talk too much
oh no has anyone ever told you that
before never good good okay truth hurts
though well you're holding I am you're
holding Harry has to has to open you up
sometimes area has to try and open your
you know calm Jerry this isn't good
all right let's walk into some tricks
okay so you got tricks we have to stop
them let's see there yeah that makes
sense let's see now what do I do
[Music]
let's see let's attack the pawn gotta
have one minute that's world knows the
time horrible huh this isn't good good
it's not good
those a time it's not good fine glad I'm
glad that we you know we know buddy job
it's a good thing I'm a good and game
player it's really good that's hoping
that's helping a lot definitely
definitely
I'm very happy for you thank you good
yeah you playing really well this the
same thing I'm trying I'm trying to
extremely impressed with your moves you
are yeah you're not easily impressed so
that's not easily no not easily but your
play in this game has been exceptionally
exceptionally something another
something or another yeah yeah again
enough I knew okay I just I just didn't
sweet I can't retreat anymore that's all
I got is your play your play is very
clever
I can't retreat anymore that's all I can
reach
King CH how do you have 3 minutes left
for move 45 yes okay
this isn't fair I don't know I have a
chance just not much but I have a chance
aha even when I trick you I'm completely
losing talk tough game that was that was
a trick man that was a trick who's gonna
drink here now there's a trick
unfortunate that was a trick that was
nasty
okay oh this isn't good come on Harry
you can win the day for me you need to
win a day for me Harry he's coming draw
yeah hope so probably stuck its
technical though its technical it's all
technical yeah its technical as long as
its technical that's all that matters
good must Pedro must be a draw easy and
any Russian about this position I will
tell you how to become it's the end of
the rail you are they gonna tell me how
to draw it
well I mean you know how to draw I'm not
sure about that last one but what are
you wrong what I know is all good it was
all good okay good it's all good
soon okay yeah I don't want to make any
mistakes my life is okay okay so what -
good it doesn't look good at all 23
seconds that's a good amount of time
it's the right amount of time I guess 20
seconds why do I have 20 seconds it's
not fair ah that's fine glazes on 20
seconds isn't good yeah that's not good
now use a time yeah it's got tons of
time
this isn't good there's good and there's
not good this is not good
this is okay you're doing you sure
you're showing your in-game technique
thank you I'm trying I didn't expect
anything less than this match I know I
always thought the problem in this match
would be my end game play yeah is that
what the problem is
yeah I feel you're holding you holding
you bu Pequod tricky that's theory still
theory being tricky it doesn't sound
like me
go Ben 11 seconds is plenty of time Lois
the time let's see
hard to trash-talk have we take you down
they ban you you're holding well I must
I am I am you did a good job let's see I
should probably move quicker then not
moving quickly enough come on Ben you
can do it not sure what you could do you
can do it I'm not sure one day neither
have to say as it I think it's clear you
and some obtain something so confused
yeah all right
seven seconds plenty of time
I think the advisory warning should be
more for your guys's chess play at this
point this might be the best players of
our chairs we're the best
I have a chance now you have a challenge
you have a good chance
free Rick Indies I've saved probably one
of my one of my apparently weak as there
is possible to get worse at rook endings
I think I don't think it's possible
this is absolutely it's give you a
slight break a slight I actually had
like how much time now two pawns
transferring I'm old I have some more
excuses too but I forgot what they were
been your share share with everybody how
I beat you wearing a costume in a rock
ending yeah that's what I want to share
yeah you played great thinking my words
you played HD is this just the worst
wreck ending over the play probably
that's probably a bad into a bad series
I know how to draw this I think you do I
think I'm I have to give you this draw
words it was going so smoothly yeah okay
well let you draw that one if you'll
sign that I tried to get involved to get
him to flag because I saw that you were
you were strong lowly slowly screwing
the I don't even know what you did there
I mean played right I mean just rematch
yeah there's still nine minutes left you
guys know how do we know when it's over
here
right what's going on you messin up my
plans here okay last time that was heads
up d okay let's try this one again so
like the way I played that game Danny
you know what you defended well after
after playing hey boys I played that
you're going out you know how should I
finish I went off I play that you're
goin what's going on here he's playing
all my openings I play sugar in D yeah
good okay I didn't know you played
Shakur well you play so fast I knew you
were rushing I mean it was clear I don't
you know any theory and then I mean
seriously dude it's like what you come
on yeah I'm innocent
my Thai foods gone I don't even think
Simon cut that yolk though that's how I
mean Simon how maybe you had by the way
buddy
let the stands out I mean I got to you
I've been all right you know to over the
evening is quite late here - why that is
is trying to keep my energy levels
together more time yes I'm actually just
trying to remember trying to remember
any theory about this at all and I'm
concentrated I'm very apologetic Simon's
doing a lot better than I expected I
mean very apologizing Bennie's playing
your own terrible repertoire against you
know exactly he's playing terrible way
that I play yeah so I guess been you
know this one yeah yeah I should Ben's
been playing dubious openings long
before he got the GM title let's keep
going ok right boy after do this like oh
it's not gonna be fluency saying nasty
what's the problem
Lissie more time that's amazing I've
decided I'm just gonna troll both of you
while you play I mean I've been sitting
here trying to work listening and
watching you guys screw up some of the
best thing I think this will say anymore
I have to be involved in called Danny
get involved you need to take some some
energy here I need to go I need to go I
need to get some little Danny uplift
here - trying to finish this match off
well if you don't like my position again
yeah so but I guess I was I pretended I
was gonna take this I guess I will okay
I'll just give some pawns you know we
need to get some things I could take
that pawn - I didn't see that yeah you
can take if I saw it I might have taken
it was this is this called the what look
rook lift and Connor tempted to do it
now alright okay well we have to play
this now well you gotta do what you
gotta do yeah now how many drinks have
you had as you're playing like about
seven drinks this is playing my normal
cause it's one of those beers with like
12% alcohol though so Simon can get away
with saying he's had to but when's the
angel you know
the engine said that he was point one -
I thought it meant his position but a
man is real alcohol that was the problem
okay cause my one - okay I was soaking
for me where is my play here I have more
time oh I've never had more time I'm so
confused
oh yeah hey let me buy you a beer after
this game you can probably you can
probably afford two after this somehow
before - give me a couple back assume
you like ginger beer based on your name
that's not a bit but you know know there
is alcoholic ginger beer
I like the Moscow Mule Wow Wow this move
Ben Wow Queen B yes that's something
that's that's like eight beers there
that was that was the movie I was trying
to stop oh dear it's a shocker
yeah I'm still gonna lose but at least
I'm happy for the moment it's gonna be
very hard to lose this position I think
my best piece I'm talented I was lucid
before you were born
then it comes again the same again oh my
words okay okay so wants to know what
you're drinking Ben is that straight
olive oil no this is a Long Island iced
tea without the Long Island yeah Walter
well it's iced tea
yeah water basically yeah that's true I
didn't realize how rubbish this type
thing wasn't on a plate
yeah I've played it a lot it's pretty
that's really bad opening Seymour's a
[ __ ] was number two in the world and
now we never heard of him because he
plays this opening so bad is this so bad
I'm not gonna be playing this one again
horrible how did you get away play nurse
if so no careful until I start playing
it are you stop playing it okay this is
just nothing nothing at all here yeah
yeah you're talking a badge here this is
yeah I mean it's here okay let's go
there does it get any worse I'm sure it
can get worse yeah yeah it's the first
time I'm pretty pessimistic about my
chances even though the score is
reflecting that you are
yeah way off yeah I mean I think
anything anything at all I think you're
doing well yeah thank you in this
position the worst trash-talking ever
yeah this is pretty bad I mean I'm just
I'm just quite happy to finish off this
five minute now
oh my words what is this this is rubbish
why is this opening I like we got to
work on some sort of time-lapse of the
colour of Simon's face throughout the
match he's getting redder and redder
small stress it is I think the pressure
is getting more pressure more pressure
every game every game I lose no but
seriously
Simon's doing a very good job pretending
I mean something a showing that he's not
shooting with an engine he's showing it
right here nobody's anything right this
is this is this is absolutely very few
people accomplish that with their best
moves
does anyone has anyone excuse me achieve
an engine Danny in this match nobody's
ever accused you of that on our server
no one's ever done now that's good
that's good to hear that's good to hear
I'm glad to hear there's no no I mean
okay this is just a move I can't think
of anything else
looks like theory it looks like it looks
like the game I lost you the first game
was this horrible well there's only one
way to do that and the toilet is getting
nearer my readings one more game do you
know yeah you guys can fit one more
infidel s' what Danny we can fit one
more in this three-way is that what
you're saying that's right one more one
more one more this is me way before you
and Simon wow you guys are keeping me on
my toes although you're getting you're
taking some heat from the chat you guys
aren't being quite as what what abusive
to each other as they'd like to see he's
the finest player in his chair well he's
not there anymore yeah yeah well the
thing is I want to say really negative
things about him but you're here so I
just can't I mean I mean he's a
grandmaster and you're you know like
sort of a fake I am right
exactly I see people at home don't know
when I got my GM norm and title you got
your I am Norman title that's right okay
I know the whole story
you do know the whole story you know
lots of stories I know stuff are true
yeah okay I want to see what he was
gonna do something else
okay he's got something Simon what you
get their way let me get some of these
nuts in my mouth
Wow these are great
what are these chocolate salty balls you
know what that's good
yeah take the jokes to a higher level
then we know what we know you got any of
many people don't know it's true really
here to get high but you can do it I
think that house gosh lis most of the
conversations Ben and I have had talked
about after we never play us three it's
a movie I guess Wow Simon are you are
you are you choosing to now be a little
more serious and get some get some
chocolate in your system rather than
Elmo I'm good I'm gonna get some
chocolate get some water three minute
I'm gonna try and try and come back in a
match a little bit see try to play some
chess in the second off I think I've
woken up a little bit now but we'll see
we'll see Danny at the moment I have to
say Ben is just hanging on every game
and I'm playing like a complete and
that's a [ __ ] so we have to try to
change that a little bit and then my
sample header at even tempo somebody
tell me hmm
apparently apparently they have this
match being featured on Twitch it's a
speed chess championship so people were
joining us and really excited to see you
know your face is on TV that works I'm
like unlucky then so alright I'll play
the theoretical move okay all in the
books I guess yeah this is the game you
know something versus something like
yeah yeah dark side complete so how does
this compared to mycosis match is it a
little bit worse qualities my part no
not not really I think you guys are I
mean Magnus said he didn't play very
well
after crushing his opponent I'm sure
that because they now feel real good
found a crush I think I didn't see the
match this day but I guess I guess he he
looked like he did well it was it was a
slaughter yeah okay I took a lot of heat
a lot of people didn't like I was
distracting the show and doing I was
advertising your match I let Ben
Feingold come on and do some promotions
of his club and people said I was being
a terrible commentator but Magnus was
crushing him and like I was bored what
okay this time as well Danny so Danny I
can hardly hit you this match I mean I
just it's nice to hear something apart
from Ben's voice I think that's just why
I'm trying to get you involved just like
just you know if you just say you know I
actually prefer your voice a little bit
I think after an hour of your voice I
might you know change mine but been
psychologically get some gets he has
trouble with me anyway because I talked
about I have a + record against him look
I we never talk about our us chess
league in let's talk about that oh
that's right that's where you beat me
and they just League you played rook
takes c6 like a boss I didn't care
losing you might as well that might be
the worst us Chesley game I played
though lucky you lost to me that's why
yeah yeah this is our last game Danny
this is your this is your last game in
the week we take a break yeah we're
gonna take a quick break we'll let you
go rub some olive oil all over your
seams I need a big break I need to read
about some well I feel gonna get rekt
made us I need a break yeah somebody at
your chess Center said they thought they
saw a raccoon but it was just your face
that's right see the thing I can't even
see the camera I don't even know how red
my face is but it isn't real right here
your spirit animals are a raccoon in a
fox a drug box Fox does that'll blunt
the saying either iconic I see thank you
think it was a car you said follow I'm
fast and [ __ ]
it's not good to be fast if you're [ __ ]
just realize okay
I've been an hour it is hour and a half
of this [ __ ] but halfway through the
match ready what the [ __ ] is that okay
right come on
finest speed this up I mean the thing is
I can't believe how badly I'm playing I
mean I can't believe how badly Ben's
played by which is just unbelievable
luckily worse than him you know
seriously Simon honestly you played
terribly I mean I just I don't want you
to feel I want you to think there's any
joking about that I'm pretty bad if I
call be not Rick ending that is bad that
is bad I don't know Danny I mean it's
like when I played rivals much you
sometimes yeah bad sometimes is
sometimes it's okay we could get banned
his own YouTube channel you guys could
do rivals regularly this is terrible
I mean people have a conspiracy that you
guys are secretly lovers in the chat
though hey it's a secret yeah this is
not good I have to say I mean I always
been angry you've been the first time I
heard it but I'm now gonna make no no no
I don't think penis is bad as I first
fool if that makes it was a complete
another [ __ ] idiots you know but now
I think he's a little bit I think he I
think he's better than I thought no bye
no I I thought he was like eighteen
nineteen hundred but he's at least I'm
21 at least eighteen nineteen hundred
well I'm at least eighty nine hundred
and this one but you know the thing is
some some games is good I mean I better
waste some time here if I lose this
match I mean Jesus not not have lost if
you lose the Sascha Pat's there as well
must mean I'm a bigot Pat's it's just
like it's like watching two if you lose
a man feels bad man the truth hurts it
is bad I have to well this is easy
defense you don't have any attack I got
the two bishops come on this I forgot to
add Ben's very suspicious line in his in
his list of accomplishments he says
solid and very suspicious position is
very suspicious I'll give you that this
position is not good I'm still gonna but
it's a terrible position
terrible
this why why am I thinking it this is
like okay
do I need to think you know let's just
take everything let's take away what you
can't do that
just take it really good let's be greedy
let's be great let's take it it's a
pretty good move let's take everything
ah let's see whose turn is it
Wow look the worst position I've ever
had except for all the other ones I had
except for all those mmm buddy this is
still theory cow what a bad position
it's good think I'm playing ginger yeah
no I say that to myself and here on the
ranch
I don't chance to say the way you could
drop me here I think you could do it you
think I could see that can you dressed
up like the Mexican you were plus 10 and
then we got to a drawing position yeah
no it's so terrible I'm pretty bad at
chess that's the good I think he was the
only person I beat in that tournament No
oh yeah that's for sure that's how bad I
was playing so you should you should
also feel good about that one I'm
playing like Sokolov I have all my
pieces like this didn't you play Yvonne
to try to crime trying to create a
little bit of sexiness in the board head
but yeah maybe I should just play some
chances no you take your time I got
nothing to do yeah now Danny is that
checker Cash when I wouldn't this match
it's actually it's actually rubles
rubles okay rubles in Bitcoin let's keep
it simple
listen let's not even win I'm a simple
guy simple needs a we keep it simple I
think simple as we can the story stock
those pieces coming in King f8 King age
youth are both good players they're both
good thank golf for the break after this
one that's all I can say me break I
think I speak for most people when I say
this is this has been highly
disappointing so I need the what you
mean your commentary is really about the
games it's just terrible common
however it is better than usual it is
better than what you but those people
don't really get you know why it's the
best and why you're the best why because
you didn't say anything that's why
that's why it's been the best show
because I always retreat always retreat
now you can retreat come on Simon you
can do it I have something I can lose
this position like an antenna break the
coupe's I have faith you could make it
any progress whatsoever only to have a
lot of faith but I have some faith
I think I think I still have faith the
way the way things are going it's been a
most disappointing match ever this is
this is another aim effort I thought the
most the most letdown that a chess calm
can have okay let's see this is risky
for me you gotta risk it to get the
biscuit them either favourite now I
guess not I think yeah I think I'm doing
a good job of I wanna favor all right
let's take everything okay you really
played this position well Simon let's
take everything thanks Danny my still
better dining am I still better that may
be no jury's out on that one
oh my was I made I made one good move in
a row one this is this is like yeah this
is not good that's not good it's time to
start begging for a draw assignment I
don't know I let's see whose turn is it
mine
the babies are not coming at the moment
I don't like anything more - hmm 40
seconds that's plenty
that's good technique so far okay well
so far I'm down to pong still Wow after
all that I'm still down to quads
damn
yeah you're good third wheel D and
you're doing a great job
yeah thanks yeah no you're doing good
yeah we're gonna need to do this one
again hopefully you brought the condoms
or something they get to do something
the third wheel should contribute in
some way right you should do something
yeah let's see my turn that's it that's
a nice night you got over there
good job well that's a good that's good
good end game play I'm making I'm making
this very easily winning position yeah I
don't think I'm very I think I think you
have drawing chances I don't think I'm
usually winning oh oh let's see do I
have a chance here IVM a chance now this
is this is going very south guys go
this isn't good from then the B pod to
win the day for Simon yeah go Ben twenty
seconds what his techniques to good 20
seconds I can't believe it how can this
how can i still lose this game how I
think the way I'm playing you to be
honest still let's see my turn 14
seconds that's good okay twelve seconds
that's a lot of time go Ben you can draw
two Pond endings maybe one pond down you
can draw let's see then I can get Forks
somehow that's good you just if no Ben
Simon was playing for a draw the whole
time huh wait man Ben Simon I've got my
draw
I know who don't Simon is then Simon
it's a mixture of Ben and Simon yep
let's see lose yet and I've not yet this
is this discount a little a little bit
disappointing just a little yeah just a
little a little bit disappointing
technique will always plug the ship FA
yeah always always played Bishop f8 is
that pong for me
I was just wondering and there we go me
I'm a you guys is it for me
oh my words [ __ ] was that I've wondered
my bishop he can take it
oh yeah take a break I'm gonna rebuild
baby
would you like those drawers do any of
the rook and pawn anything in that one I
was terrible how many points that was I
Danny I mean like I was looking at me 27
oh yeah I'm gonna play I'm gonna play
the video five minutes you uh you think
you might repair for this match maybe
that'll help you get a little more
pumped up as you Clyde a video I'll be
back in a couple of minutes then you go
how many minutes do whatever you want I
mean I can't even beat you guys anymore
all right well okay despite how bad
Simon looked he actually apparently said
he did some preparation for this match I
uh I don't really believe it anymore but
we're gonna we're gonna go ahead and
play we're gonna play Simon's match
because it gives all of us a chance to
have a break and if you missed this
video subscribe to Simon on on YouTube
and he's got a twitch channel he's
pretty awesome let's support these guys
so go ahead and take a take a listen
into this pretty hilarious video that
Simon put on the web a couple days ago
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't see the chat anymore
all right we're still waiting for Simon
I don't see the chats where I type in
the zoom you know you can chat in zoom I
don't see it yeah that's weird
you have to fill it with buttons today
buddy no it's not there well Ben I mean
I did pick you to win this match so I'm
not gonna lie this is about what I
expected as much as I want to pretend I
thought but my friend sent me a text you
said this is the best comment so far
from somebody what a pair of morons no
there have been some really good ones
some good insults to you both what a
performance
yeah we've but we've got some
subscribers we I'll remind everybody
while I'm still here that um that any
any subscribers donations tips anything
today to the twitch TV slash chess
channel gets donated to charity probably
Ben's charity of choice given the way
things are going Ben who you gonna
donate you some sort of hurricane relief
Yeah right I mean oh yeah the guy who
donated the guy from Iowa yeah he said
of course we'll you don't it's gonna be
to your chest Center
he wrote that of the email to me yeah so
he wanted me to get the money that was
his plan so you can pay yourself so that
means officially I have nothing to do
with the Chess Center officially
officially that's right you know what
there's a lot of to you who are really
good with those that paperwork right
that's right you sound like a good
politician there I'm married to the
owner yeah those were tough to draw
those lost engines but somebody has to
do it yeah no I know you you're you're
holding your own as sellable says after
this
right what what we're waiting for Simon
now there is yeah that's what Tom Gaul
said hello noise hello hello Johnny were
the best he said who now we're good
Simon Danny in case you lost track we've
been keeping track for you you
officially have more bathroom breaks
than points so okay right well we need
to start playing now yeah yeah we've had
some suggestions for you to come back in
the match desert storm Karl suggests
maybe you get some Twinkies or some food
and open and open it on air to distract
Ben so that's one idea your chest movies
aren't doing it for you today buddy
they're not working at the moment all
thanks well have we watched your we
watched your your preparation which was
really great
yeah the anyway band did you do any prep
what we have you here for the next round
yeah I went to the store and I bought
Perrier and iced tea so I was ready for
the match yeah and I have cough drops
cuz I got a you know talking stuff so
that was good prep I feel like you've
had a coffee your entire life well you
know that's that's the way life you know
what are you gonna do the truth hurts
alright well you guys are both doing
great
oh yeah I'm I don't even it doesn't
matter
they said speech me speechless I'm
speechless
that's one thing all right guys are you
ready to play three minute now let's
give it a guy this listen if anything
can happen now come on bang yeah like I
said the parental advisory for this is
really for your guys's chess moves much
less about your potty mouths but
definitely bad moves okay so I got a
place faster no I'm gonna go back out
for a little bit here come on let's get
good touching there's two things I hate
in life people intolerant of other
people's cultures and the Dutch well the
Dutch culture something like that I
don't know whatever the gold thing
so by now I guess you thought you're
gonna have more points than this before
to start but I mean I can't live
expectations' there you go yeah okay
let's do it in this plate let's let's
change this now three-minute time it's
time to get some action in noting that
for this enough of this mr. crap guy
chess I'm playing no don't do that we've
got we got afro hurry up there okay
salmon we've got an hour we've got an
hour of three minutes can I get the full
points back and at least make it
interesting let's try come on hurry get
in there new blood needed turn is it my
turn yeah I guess so yeah otherwise
Harry's coming I guess but you know
right because we gonna live to fight
another day you remember we talked about
right who me and you yeah when we talked
about that the match needs to stay
within five games here your ass goes
down I thought you said four okay you
can win this game that's it we were
texting back and forth and you kept
changing your mind yeah well I don't you
can't be a whitewash I don't know all
right
she okay I don't like this position I
never liked my position so I should be I
should be happy your position seemed I
know okay let's at least use Harry let's
get Harry hasn't woken up yet
maybe I am woken up but Harry is now at
least getting up the boards - come on
Harry
good come on we need to show a little
bit of chess now definitely I need to
get a calculate even when I get winning
positions but every face upon you might
not take it well you might not maybe
maybe I should take this one Ben I think
I probably have to yeah I didn't see it
okay I'm gonna take it Ben yes all right
good gonna see what you got one move I
didn't get mated that was nice all right
what's taking things in case it works so
he's a pawn it's just a pool all right
something yeah
back we can't maybe who's texting me
great job so far they're talking to me
or you probably TV been probably to you
fun fun enough I haven't got any
messages like that myself this moment
I'm first one I go yeah good stuff you
did a good job then yeah it's impressed
one person see the good news is you know
there's people here at the chess Center
watching the bad news is they all threw
up watching you play so they don't
they're not impressed with our match I
have to say I'm a little bit let down
but away on plank so far - it's still
three men I still have to play faster
well I don't play chuck it when I play
fast mmm good so tight takes a man
see that's why Magnus isn't as good as
us he wins pawns and plays with good
technique that's anybody could do that
we play a different style we play for
the people I think as she had the minor
I'm just playing crap this is the style
- Magnus could I take this pawn the
crowd you take it so I guess so I guess
you can I was wondering I was wondering
about it they're wondering I'm gonna
take this a lot of fun here I'm taking
stuff oh Jesus Christ
I think it's start what the hell my
thing yeah okay can it get any worse
no your Knights probably better than my
run probably I'll always play Bishop f1
all right Roy pain there you go you got
you got the five game start there yeah
oh he's not mad at me oh I hope he's
okay Danny every 25 min let's see you
chuck meet me here well I can have to
keep coming at you so we need a big kiss
can be late now yeah that's what the
people want
yeah they what of people want but what
does they want something I don't know
how the pieces move just the party just
the point okay so I see I haven't
studied this since before Jani was born
yeah well you see see the beard that's
how old I am
yeah you got pretty old what's it five
games
bloody hell
who could have predicted well a lot of
people yes I was kidding
yeah I'm at machine shock how badly is
going but you know this is okay what do
you mean I think it I think that money
you know you can have to think about
what sherry you're gonna give it to ya
hopefully hopefully some charities are
gonna well okay get something you know
three-minute is tough I don't like this
three-minute Freeman is tougher but open
to that last game yeah right now what's
going on here let's I have more time
okay one more time quicker quicker you
won't be playing the Kings gambit
against you again I'm gonna realize
they're not too good I see the Kings
gambit is maybe something you know a
little bit about what see take take take
take take take and then I resigned
because I've no pieces left all right
okay glad you saw taking that one cuz of
course I saw that that will go here
refused I have the two bishops I saw the
two bishops yes very long can I take it
on b7 I can I can i still take i'm
always sacrificing pawns because I see a
lot I'm still you know I'm still just
worried about a lot of stuff that's why
it's actually the tactics T come happen
so okay
okay some porn up that's a good start
sterling oh oh damn all of five games
otherwise there's no way what is no way
back anyway so is there any way back
here there any way back my flag falls on
this move I'm gonna lose the match yeah
well I have to walk into all kinds of
stuff
alright I'll walk into it gonna walk
into it sometimes right I'm walking into
it yeah at wanted me to remind you been
that Taco Bell is not an accepted
charity what no wait a minute we
discussed this beforehand if it's south
of the border and it's it's acceptable
south of the border south of the border
my pieces do all crumbled up there
looking at me you don't you don't know
they've been fine goal charity it's a
fine it's a fine institution
94 yeah I didn't see that this is the
first time I've been greedy in the match
so far
so I can I have to be greedy again sure
thing I'm gonna play this crazy move
again okay you're tend to crazy like
boxing yeah I'm gonna play crazy okay Oh
Mike you're gonna get you committed in a
Kings gambit Simon what at the moment I
could get chip mated in literally any
position I could get checkmated everyone
knows that I used lots of Phil you are
is is is it's good moment takes takes
takes I don't know that's complicated
it's kind of this is my queen saying I
should move it okay okay can one the
Queen's hanging again hangs every move
the only Falcon three now is just too
tight your Queen anything else to do all
right
no Ben I still have less time you're
attacking me
oh it's annoying know what you to attack
me like this
now we beat you in one war it's time to
beat you in another USA the colonies
fight back oh wow what's going on here
my down upon still what he played again
but why my down upon what was there
cheating going on here this is like
shouldn't be done upon something I'm not
sure I know why I like my position
because I moved Harry and he didn't move
Harry that's why you can do that I don't
think so I don't think I could use a lot
of time and try to dig in somewhere so
use all my time you feel calm please get
quicker so are my words the five minutes
section right okay
I've still got a pool and I've still got
a porn but you're coming in at my king
right we have to take this one my choice
okay let's I don't like coming for me
you coming at you coming to take
everything alright let's do it let's
push feingold is that what it's called
it might be obvious management you can
make a cog you can name anything after
you what's
it's let's push him a time let's see now
what I'm out of ideas
that was my only idea there I push them
again right then you know I'm actually
now starting to grovel again she this is
the only thing I can do I just have to
take groveling chess are not just
getting crushed here yeah well I don't
know I mean I'm groveling surely more
time I'm trying to grovel around to what
I'm good at drawing these endings down
several plans very good well I mean this
is this is normal for you I mean this is
better this is why three pawns or
something so so this is this is
definitely definitely improvement or
something everyone's okay that guys know
what they're going once the pawns are
dropping you know yeah all right now I
have more open file 'yes yes yeah yeah
now I'm doing well you're doing well sir
it's the best position I could have
hoped for
so this is probably what happened
probably something I should be winning a
good day I'll be winning this one so
does it feel like a good day to think
what maybe maybe a ginger day today this
moment in time but we still have time
I'm not gonna give up yet we have to
keep fighting a little bit I mean I've
got three blooming pawns three you
should give up that's a lot of pawns
that's a lot of points why I have
warrant files I think now is probably
it's probably like odds on to be a draw
now probably err with frame I'm a slight
favor two points still favorite kind of
slight favorite always flight okay this
is worse than usual that's impossible
I mean you gained some awful positions
but for somehow I'm awfully good you you
you know well I thought about I think I
think it's more I'm awfully bad yeah
it's something feel I think I'm playing
Oh see these guys are used to Magnus he
can't play chess like that that's too
off-putting yeah that's this is the way
people want to see yeah yeah we're
playing like Danny wrench style over
here Lisa moves we miss some stuff yeah
with any place you know I mean I'll play
Danny he's quite dangerous to this so
yeah okay come on I see you in this way
through the attack attack okay so that
should that worked right come on pawns I
want to see March
move my king up in the end game that's
pretty good yeah I think I got this
yeah I'm just not sure what I got I
think it there okay I'll take that
that's good good technique of course I
saw it I'm gonna take everything how's
that okay
good play good play make everything okay
I thought if I get rid of one pawn to
simplify the position I've said you get
rid of all your pawn to simplify I think
so yeah yeah I think this is my clam
right what the hell no you can do it I
can do this Jesus this is why you're the
endgame maestro yeah well something
somewhere I mean to be honest you don't
need to be much at the moment yeah
you are something I give you that flea
train wreck I can't be any I think I've
been something is just literary jinx me
I mean my play maybe it's just
completely I could be yeah I think my
play he's just pinned or worse yeah this
is obviously a favor here but right free
porn all right let's play Knight f3 it's
the same thing I mean seriously yeah
just slap you in the face right I know I
know is it's not getting any better okay
okay come on
I mean I'm caffeine Bo this is this I
can't win but he's extra pawn so let's
go okay come on let's push show the a
pawn that's sort of like here right
what's called re he was called out in
the apron area the April not Harry is
bad brother and okay so we're getting
more touched action now more dodge
action but still the five points and the
time is going and all the points are not
coming time to recover
we'll say one of the things I'm
surprised about is that you haven't gone
bald yet I'm you should be excited about
that we what did I do
I don't know I just always expected you
would go bald as you got old alright I I
mean this he wasn't good but it's in the
spirit of the match so we're doing what
I
I think literally if I don't if I don't
win a game
hey very soon I'm just gonna get
completely wasted on air I'm just gonna
give up all now I'm just gonna give up
on the chess and just drink heavily so
okay this is maybe your theory better
that way
well let's see well Harry pushing him
you got some little checks here yep I
got h4 and I'm good I'm very proud of
age four that's good psychology let's
just get this one out how do I still
have less time all right let's get let's
play this thing let's castle play the
safe okay kill him all right we got a
push and Harry somehow you push it Harry
coming at me this looks okay you
actually don't hit my position now and I
always hit my position yeah the first
time I don't hate it my position seems
right but I'm just hating myself all the
way I'm playing no but you have good
endgame technique I want to recommend
very good very good and got cement of
the viewers your your DVDs on endgame
technique because they can't be any
Wesley's or winning with extra material
more DVDs than gingy play up three I
played up three
oh my god how could I have done such a
thing
Simon dude you can yes pull it together
buddy come on don't do it at least at
least I didn't see there don't you just
get something happening here don't
something try to close the gap a little
bit for what do I do
is this still time Danny G thing is this
still time I mean you can still break
the record for the biggest loss in the
history of the so you can still time
yeah there is time for it to go either
way yeah you can bro break all kinds of
a little bit of time well now what do I
do Ben they're requesting in the chat
that you auction off your GM title and a
raffle after this well that's they
wouldn't get much for it so I don't know
why these already gone why do you want
it won't get anything for it let's see I
guess I have to retreat
still time that's all I need sorry I
don't want to retreat okay I'll retreat
that's the most aggressive move we could
we begin another ending its I keep
moving my knight around till he's dizzy
I'm just gonna grab grab that one
because why not
I'm gonna do something when the chips
are down yep it's gonna grab those
floors it's almost similar to how
Carlson beat self
yeah thank you
you reckon it were in that way as well I
reckon do you reckon with end in a
similar way you know meet me although
every point you win I get more nervous
about the end games every every point I
win it seems to get worse it's another
ending Bend it's another ending
I mean I think the thing is at least if
I come back from this you'll be one of
the biggest comebacks I used to it well
I will do a raffle then everybody will
do a one-year Diamond membership raffle
for the chat so you can enter the raffle
will do a will auction off to somebody I
don't know why I just I've been excited
about giving away anything today this
positions not good you guys are taking
the charitable this right out of me
let's see what do I do
I do feel a bit like here what's his
name the green [ __ ] of my new boy king
b1 grinching away with my position even
when I'm a pawn up on thing very well
something needs to give something up on
my position what happened again I've got
a good position but it's not good oh
yeah you're rooting for you yeah I
forgot about that
well you're rooting for the wrong guy
Simon if you walk your King gauge for
you could probably get him mated there I
you know I don't even say that because
you know these things these things are
looking very possible especially
especially when I love that little guy I
am the favorite okay I'm just not sure
what I'm the favorite at but something
is how are you gonna win or am I just
gonna get mated is it Harry mmm well
we're see it's still a porn yeah it's
unfortunate
they're eggs let's go counter-attack or
something hey that's don't do that I
didn't see come on Harry
just at least win one game for me see
that let's block here that age point
locating here for you blockade very
tricky I try so actually Jesus okay so
far so good yes so far on places like
Magnus on drugs you point like Magnus oh
very very bad trucks so then I'll kick
it in today can I promote my bishop to a
queen you trying to you saying nasty
stand I want to promote my bishop okay
this is still theory that's the weird
part
c20 saying nasty why do I always have
less time against this guy let me he's
British I thought he was slow well no
I'm just bad today
Wow wait that's a good move alright
let's do that such a baby he wants his
Queens attacked based on how he's
playing let's say come on so far so far
everything under control yeah we're just
waiting for the breaking point it's not
gonna happen in this game money to win
maybe every game
maybe call me maybe
yeah let's defend that one well what's
happening an apple it's just you know
that's the way he's got a serious just
in case just got a serious drinking
problem in serious just in case happen
so I'm not gonna do all this game
okay I guess like a Frenchman it's the
only way I can play a Frenchman again
like a Frenchman this position it's not
good there's good and there's not good
this is not good
but I have no time so I should be okay
right right let's see the legendary
Simon Williams technique on I a legend
the legendary legendary technique okay
how about that for a start is that is
that okay are you being a move okay
every move I'm just trying not to
blunder a piece and as soon as I get a
role going
that thing's a queen so I shouldn't do
that okay I didn't hang my queen I'm the
best 27 seconds and dead lost okay I'm
feeling it I'm feeling it okay because
to me it yet or not yet because he have
forced mate do I have forced mate as
long as somebody does that's all that
matters and I was coming in I get a
little bit scared of coast yeah that's
what she said
no weird things going on it is scary
yeah it's scary stuff
okay I'm catching up on time this is
take your time I move there let's see
fish with eggs all right whoa I tried to
move it it wouldn't let me good I guess
here there's no meat in one yet okay
good technique so far so far the usual
technique the usual Wow good play by
good play by me so far so good
okay I didn't even see them I have no
time okay let's go here twelve seconds
that's all out of time
well I didn't see that either Wow cheese
whatever they're paying us to play this
match because we're so good I knew there
was a reason well this isn't good this
position he's not good let's see that
legendary technique I'm trying my best
Ben you looks like you are legendary
yeah I'm taking everything BOTS okay
he's taking everything he's doing it
it's legendary
it's legendary it's still theory always
play King bee one that looks like
another draw solid game okay we have to
go solid solid good good good technique
it's very good okay let's go let's keep
going
legendary technique as long as it's
legendary nothing's good unless it's
legendary alright it's still legendary
let's see I have no time still ok good
isn't so good it's not good twenty
seconds
hi so many pawns it's a little put on so
many pawns so many let's see oh this
isn't good 19 seconds yeah yeah this
isn't good oh yeah I don't see what to
do oh good
alright I'll make a legal minute I'll
make a legal on legendary technique does
it again I can't believe it oh my gosh
you have a chance here for the first
time no I have a chance you have a
really good chance let me show what kind
of shot took a chance
there you go you know I'm just I'm just
keeping every game close
even when I'm winning every game now now
I feel better okay coming in a row am I
still hurt you're still thinner right
pin him do I have time do I have time
mister wrench because you got like 35
minutes okay that's cool still fury
westeros area
well played before all right we'll take
this maybe he wants to he took back darn
okay so I was hoping he wouldn't all
right I don't think I played too well
there Kim I could be wrong we have
played great yeah yeah you're right you
didn't play well but I can't tell
sometimes yeah it's hard to tell
okay this move still theory okay we're
going to use re no wait wait a minute
what what's his name arrey arrey arrey
the apron all right everything's up for
the beta the moment confused us a little
here all right I have more time I
haven't hung a piece yet I'm the best
okay what we're doing here I don't know
let's just do this I'm not sure the
British guy can't tell is a pawn from
his aged pawn yeah that's why they say
ours because they don't know how to
pronounce with the a let's see there my
turn
come on f5 is sort of this is sort of a
three minute move let's do that it's
time to pull in three minutes
that's all I can do it otherwise I can't
I think if you try any tricks against
wait a minute - okay I want a game in a
free minute I'm very happy and very
happy I've won again yeah very happy
yeah but you go you go you still with
tricks your trickster
tricks are for kids yeah I have more
time I can't believe it man the last
game what's been good how do I lose that
I can I was only the only three pong all
right my turn
let's see my case yeah you suck you make
affect retreat like a Frenchman okay
must be dumb yeah
always retreat f6 never play f6
never f6 I don't understand why not the
first thing I don't think my music that
understandable that's a good to be
honest all right I'll take maybe it's
good see the good or terrible yeah my my
usual is this is still theory but even I
don't believe it some things I don't
believe feel like I swindled them today
I don't think I ever promised them good
chess what was wrong with that you take
stuff since was great I play one good
movie game you're the one who called
this week GM's you know mr. week I am I
mean Danny sir I sure did call you guys
week GM's you guys are the kind of GM's
I aspire to be today though
come on you sticking to the beach in st.
Danny playing on the h-file night eh
tonight h4 we put it in H president
never realized my full potential I think
although I is a pattern I might be able
to be a 40 year old GM once I retire
from chess calm yeah does anyone else
fight this right well well what was your
idea of that move I've even no idea what
my idea was what this is okay I'm very
I'm very busy
well nice five need to get rid of this
guy that's a good move let's just try
swap off get an ending but this time I'm
not even porns up so yeah okay I'm not
down any material yet okay good night
then well you didn't much pay the most
game about that all right let's play the
anti positional move yeah that's pretty
antsy positional okay I'll do it I like
it
he's coming in it's it's good for blitz
chess otherwise they have no comment so
I luckily luckily I said I can't
actually see the chat today because I'm
using all-time you think it's a very
good thing how could it be good I'm
using them computer to what I normally
use yeah no excuse I have more time I've
I can see I can see the chat is cetera
okay so I can sack my queen and then he
won't take it and then what happens I
think I'm gonna do it anyway sack my
work I could lose on time one thinking
about it but a hundred wondering this is
fun this is fun for the crowd look at
this position we're having fun over here
someone having fun are they yeah see
okay so I'm glad I'm not you know never
play a hundred but it's like favor one
who's watching the Magnus game yesterday
now is well this is a different kind of
chess it's fair to say it's a different
kind of chess is interesting
see we know what we know what the fans
want Bishop age six
I don't have any tricks okay come back
he took that didn't see the ax
all right he fell for it he took that
eye that poison pawn full and fallen
into something yeah again yeah okay an
NRI drawer look slightly
very likely play a couple of moves first
just by too likely but just just to see
right so I'm down upon so that's good
once I'm down two pawns I'm ready to
play when it's two pawns then I get then
I get really worried around the bishop
before it's good you know one pull in
one point I'm okay it's just one point
up I still feel quite confident once I
get ready for was just terrible so two
good moves it arose that alone is it's
definitely first time you get to that's
too loud I think the thing is the only
reason I'm losing this match is is
because of my blunders with the
sacrifice I think you handle I think
it's because if you're fine play that's
why you're losing I think I think my
blunders a fine play kill atrocious but
uh okay all right now I have good
counter play for the exchange can move
can move miss that one am i if I win
this my only free games down bet that
would be I don't always shocking you
said it should be more I say if that's a
big if as well so big if at the moment
to get back into this position is just
terrible it's pretty bad pretty bad but
I mean you've done you've done better
been come on show she class sure she
class come on
but we're gonna fight now I'm just gonna
drink beer okay good okay so this is
just awful
it's pretty bad gotta go fuel a bad for
you when I win this game I just feel
terrible
much to lose the next one on purpose
Dania what's the rule four or five is
five five is the spread buddy okay and
what am i head now Europe before okay so
I'm not doing anything wrong yet yeah
I'm the best keep Simon in the match me
next next to me person
what's the tak next to me perfection is
crap I'm the best yeah well it rhymes a
little bit in rhyme every every Kingdom
is terrible this isn't good
alright maybe he was a good move there
it was you know Queen seeds who might
refute that ya know
that's why I might I'm not saying it
would I said it might you know that's
why it was suggesting it that's saying a
hundred percent let's see there let's
take it I don't see any mates I don't
see tonight I believe it's but I'll see
a mate and lost a mate if I actually got
two in a row Eskew world has changed you
told me to make it close my words why
she want to know Mike never okay
calculated Simon got his first win since
before the war and he follows it with
another winning so we're gonna have to
end this is where that that that really
hidden softy
is starting to doubt in you we know you
hide it well but don't let your soft
spot show okay I won't get hard now so
also what oh let's play like let's play
like Harry over here what's good here
you go can see my theory is well
develops in these things so you're using
an area against me but when we play with
here I mean okay let's I don't like
anything position so if I win free in a
row what are the bets on that Danny if I
wouldn't free the right is anyone could
take a near you can take any bets on
that Danny the line on there people are
upset you haven't told them to stick it
in its pipe and do something with it yet
wow I know I can only do that when I
want to get a couple of wins I mean it's
very hot because I just sit at this
jabber jabber you know the whole time
and it's like super jabber jabber jabber
jabber jabber jabber jabber any saw some
hard so but yeah when we do that after a
couple more wins I feel so to put it in
the pipe and smoke it and if anyone's
got that point now then yeah Cheers
alright the Jeep one set of the aged
pawn I don't know if that's right that
could be a terrible mistake so what is
this a worse position for me well I like
your position maybe I'm not the one to
ask though yeah you know let's see I
mean you know I think you're a lot
better here yeah as usual okay
I'm softened time in these games
well I've never been so up in time in my
life never so no I'm not used to you
never light your position that's true I
think there's a good reason for that
your position I think I have a good
reason for never like in my position the
thing is all you have to do against me
just go backwards and forwards it seems
I am good at that yeah if you go
backwards and forwards and always
backwards and forwards things were okay
I still have less time you still have
yeah less time all right okay so you're
not there anything on the kingside
I'm not you'll tend to me into playing
this one so I have to do it whether it's
good or bad we have such fun and now we
have to go for it we have to go for
broke on the queenside so come on that's
what you do let's let's see nice little
car me well keep things under control
let's play course pretty calm okay
that's a nice move I like that it's calm
yeah that's sick if I'm gonna lose to
her I might as well lose three in a row
I'm not a turkey for nothing that's a
vicious me that one I'm trying to get
the time back here okay well I'm gonna
I'm gonna gonna grab it there I didn't
see that exchange I was looking at other
exchanges you could win yeah I don't see
that one okay now let's go remember not
to castle sometimes you lose everything
that happens let's see where's my queen
so we got a queen side attack yeah
things going on I'm just gonna in this
game the only thing I can do is just
take as much as I can I can't do
anything else here I've got to take
everything take everything that's not
good for me let's do it you're gonna try
check maybe as oh yeah I'm good for me
I'll try yeah I think you are you have a
chance yeah what's the time situation no
chance you have laser time okay loads of
time very suspicious play by me as usual
I'm just gonna take everything you only
found okay just take everything that's a
good take as much as I can
gonna tell you that one can take him on
are we playing bunkhouse I need some
bughouse extra here Simon don't castle
have anything I'm glad you caught in
that one they did sack everything that
was good so I need to get you in these
murky positions yeah this is her only
chance okay don't you win every game
how's it your only chance
well I mean if I get you an endings you
seem to be pretty good at these so if I
just take you on some messy position I
have some chance it got some chances
alright okay so let's see the show page
six was a good move
that was good me it was yeah cause cause
me some both of them so really yeah a
little bit concern yeah so some ideas
you have let's see no have no ideas okay
have no time and I'm dead lost now I can
start playing yeah uses for is that okay
so in this it's actually free in a rose
that's that correct am I just fooling
myself if you win if I win yeah when I
win this I can take your the good
chances to win
I have chances yeah good chances yeah
good chances okay come on I'm still
rooting for me this is more like it
this is more like it I like it come on
come all the way to play we're slowly
but surely getting back into this Susan
good that's thirty chance that's cheap
that's the only thing I got that's cheap
but it's - fine gold I'm cheap what
could I do
at least I spotted it yes that's more
than I'm defending on the third-ranked
I'm impressed I spy it actually yeah
another day I would not have seen that
yeah okay so you got some this I got
something I'm not sure what it is
my doctor said I should look into it
it's not good okay I'm gonna play so bad
what am i for kids yeah okay let's do
this I see like the people who are
watching are you gonna take on age five
or are you gonna are you gonna see glory
chest are you gonna do
yeah I don't think I'm gonna do it sky
Queen that would be terrible
go Ben your attacks too strong something
something like that okay come on let's
just go for it come on time for the
party that's one of the moves that wins
yeah I'm trying to keep it going it's
time to bloomin attack always so what
it's missing about god of attack man
attack back in a match good at least at
least make you work for your own good
work your tune after and this is not
good not good okay you need a big move
okay yup three pawns here didn't even
sacrifice anything damn oh maybe no
uncle an ending I could be a my a my
head in this match though no worrying
about him alright I'm doing what you
said Danny will making it close no Danny
just left he's bored can't believe I'm
have to go for an ending
I can't believe Jenny left no I believe
it I can believe him this anything looks
pretty good I've seen I've seen I've
seen anything sliced before dumped it's
pretty good always played mystery but
fades good okay pretty good
forty seconds now you keep the pressure
up so how many pulls off I can't even
count just three just free okay is that
another one is that it
thank you I hope I have a good position
here is that good move or not no it's
terrible because the you don't get the
roll you don't get the I'm so mad
it's good to see him until come on let's
make it four let's do this again I'm
rooting for me oh [ __ ] you Danis go me I
forgot I forgot you do this I don't
actually know anything that's cause I'm
all that I'm tired I don't think my idea
was to stamina wise for I've certainly
started a bit slow okay
is an opening let's see what about this
one let's let's get the tricks good well
great game but I've never heard of it
I already know it I think I use my M
safest ok right that's the safest one
Santos I just well agreed gambit it's
been a while yeah well I'm gonna keep
the tricks going for my fourth come on
so can we talk about one second
yes so this is where I knew I was
Detroit a row this is further pieces in
this just Froderman got to keep frying
them in now it's just awful energy level
coming up I guess this is a some sort of
theory probably it is right so no is it
a theory I move forth but it looks like
that looks like a normal needed to make
could be it could be theory probably all
theory let's assume this is a
theoretical position I'm not sure about
six okay I always play this [ __ ] yeah
great move
looks like you're doing well here again
Ben wait that's not a bit above six
isn't a theorist it's playing with you
now now we give a role game I need two
more to equal to score yeah that's good
mouth pretty good
I'm surprised interest it's better than
your chess thankfully all these slow at
the moment your chess has been I mean I
know I know you just go backwards and
forwards a lot but yeah I mean okay I
mean are you actually gonna do something
this mattress if the wait for me to make
bad news keep making beard was okay not
sure
oh come on this is play I'm not sure it
was the last time you had a drink a
second ago I'm trying to you know I
think that you know it's like anything
you need to get the right level surely
yeah yeah yeah have I found the right
level yet no chance
is this your theoretical position is
still yeah I mean I mean look again I
mean I'm sorry but I just don't
understand I never liked it don't
understand your moose just don't know
which ones don't you understand I can
help you well not many of them you know
it seems pretty you know I mean seems
like you came back with some fours
waiting for me to blunder we
very good likelihood that that may occur
I hope same as as also obviously the
hope here I have apart from that I mean
I don't know you just you just getting
positionally in trouble another games
playing great I got a work on d8 behind
my passport potential pair spawn
potential nice solid chess yeah it's
nice as I'm trying okay well I think
developing is always good so just get
this guy off you see what you're doing
oh yeah gonna get out of this one have
you ever lost four in a row Ben I guess
you have okay today school with Danny
where's your turn okay and the reality
well minus one maybe okay how do you
think your position is here it's pretty
annoying this is a good night and I know
annoying as I've been playing chess with
you for two hours
that's pretty annoying well I tell you
what with that voice you can't get more
noise this is it's been great you're
grained on me for the first hour and a
half and now I focus my inner self I
mean okay you try these flash moves
that's fine me I try you know now I've
managed to focus out your voice my chess
has become a lot stronger soon it took
me to be so bloody long yeah to just you
know absorb that voice into my son easy
it's not easy let's see this legendary
ain't green check me it's real it's a
real challenge but now I believe now
that I have done that I feel like now
that voices now I can just get to a
state of harmony is quiet in it yeah now
we can see your true true strength so
I'm okay so Ben you're fighting you're
playing well you're playing well you're
fighting back in this one I'm trying
it's impressive stuff I'm trying okay
well this is the legendary technique
it's lechery Ben okay IRA's is coming
for you okay that sounded a little a
little slower it's probably only a
little
there has to be more slurring oh no I
need to get slurring going on yeah they
might worst always probably know
probably noise I have less time know
what I want yeah what legend okay
yeah this is this is this has gone a
little bit okay I didn't lose yet that's
good there's always good news
alright legendary legend I'm rooting for
Ben team Ben alright I caught up on time
you have and maybe position as well the
technique is not as bad as it was it's
not as bad as it was so I'm just gonna a
little bit I the confidence I'm just
very you're probably not me alright I'm
ahead on time it's never happened
I'm so confused very confused go Ben
have some piri you'll feel better be for
what again yeah that's trying that's a
move okay let's go okay let's try to
home takes okay I can take a bishop I
know how to do that and I can always
retreat you know me I like to retreat
you can you know you know me right
Stubbs extremely well calculate from me
again yeah well I like to retreat sure
the compensation it's the legendary
technique it's pretty oh that was pre
legendary okay one final conk its
endings I've gotta tell you earlier the
endings are just working is legend yeah
well you were too solid in these endings
yeah I'm gonna take my time here so we
have fewer games to play
oh that's crafty how long do we have
left Danny in this section now let's see
if I hear about you or about 14 we got
14 minutes left in the three minutes and
we got bullet okay I've got more games
here maybe depending how long this one
goes no you should you off that was a
good game
that was a nice comeback for you so okay
so now as for is it footnote friggin
okay by force when I play d4 this isn't
so good alright more Dutch times is
small Dutch yeah alright maybe he won't
see his queens hanging when I want to
play h4 but I don't want to play it that
badly no me don't want to play it just
on gambit Ben that's the way you'd be
doing I've never heard of it
what's this daunting game but it's
definitely not efore right takes okay
this looks familiar
I think I lost this game yeah I lost
that game alright most accessible Queen
side because that was fun it was a messy
game yeah I wasn't good I see is good
alright always play King d1 good start
okay I'm out of ideas maybe he won't see
it
give me like I mean who was people are
talking about British chess and the chat
I think they're right who was the first
British PM
she just completely jumped the shark on
playing dubious openings openings I mean
who was the first British TM who just
who started this trend so you talking
about you talking about the Dutchman
Saints Julius that's a bit hard 20 miles
Tony maws was there he was the first
ever English grandma I was miles yeah it
was miles and he played it you played it
be obviously co-op off of 186 as well
you know so he was maybe one of their
leaders and dubious openings but okay
I'll Singlish you know we like this
stuff we don't like too much preparation
I guess that's one way don't like
anything okay how is this now it doesn't
look good for me our fingers looking any
things looking up for me it's all good
not so I'm not losing on time no
well let's see I don't like v4 or
retreating my Knights but I'm gonna do
one of them I can see dude you can't
backwards in life always retreat
time for some re action that's what I do
bones get in there
this is awful this is just terrible
it's okay this is the most weakening but
I can't find so I'll play it I couldn't
find him or weakening move so you think
you got any more bets on how much I'm
gonna slur by the end of it Danny is
that something people are taking bets um
did I get so bad a chest was alright I'm
eating a sandwich
Danny was it okay okay Annie was always
this bad at chess tell you know I always
really I thought it was like a recent
thing I looked up to you Wow okay so you
wouldn't in realize what was going on at
some point okay okay that loses that
loses okay I'll play one of the losing
moves Julia flash was also a big
proponent of dubious opening trade
hodgson miles that whole generation just
yeah I like all those guys once it was a
great guy yeah yeah is a great guy but
he also terrible openings yeah right
honey
oh yeah I know Julia know I've told you
that story where I I told he was my hero
in Vegas and he looked right at me and
then just went right back to playing
video games I couldn't even give me like
an acknowledgment
not for nothing into so he was a I had
just won like a couple grand played the
trap house key in the last round and
then I saw him playing area 51 that
alien video game
you know yeah classic classic it was
like Hodgson I got so you're my hero you
look right at me
yeah we're right back to playing video
games didn't say on the story three
against me I move 14 his flag fell I
love that he had meat in three you can
just check check me it's time ran out so
there you go then he quit chest as he
lost to me that's how I win that's the
only way I could win you'd a punch of
English plays and I was gonna make fun
of B for but it turns out it was good
plan I was somehow the the bear is
kicking in I was already today in front
of before but it was a good move I it
wasn't me you know yeah I was gonna make
fun
ah how am i ahead in this match because
ideally explain it to me cuz I'm playing
worse than you I think which is can't
believe we played worse than right well
oh I think somehow somehow I'm quite
worse than you in this match which I
don't understand at all it's possible
yeah at all terrible
well I didn't resign yet that's that's
the plus well that would be a plus isn't
life you are playing me saying yeah this
is at least I have no time so at least
I'm consistent one of the legendary in
technique let's see it
I don't an ending I've given up on
endings no I don't want to get to an
ending right III think the diamond
member is what they're want their money
back
I mean I hate guy backwards in life but
you have to I don't see any good wounds
I got a move Harry can we get to an
ending if we can get to an ending I'm
gonna get worried but I've got to avoid
this ending at all costs no ending
please no ending what to do
I'll give it up if I gets an ending I
think I'm just gonna resign in future
opera or a forger or something yeah
those are all good options I think so
ok but you still you still loads up
you'll know something life is good
this is terrible ah I got to stick to
playing Danny that way I can get my - 1
be great yeah I thought Danny was a
Bandhan game player but then those watch
me he's the best end game player he's
ever seen yeah I guess as you get older
though you know when your wits go and
stuff you can oh you know you have to
play endings
anyway live as such
this isn't good myself it's not good oh
you guys are all yelling at me about the
internet but yeah once the network Oh
Danny Internet issue completely uneven
thinking about this guy okay okay I
didn't lose on time yet so that's good
it's a plus no but I'm trying
yeah maybe madness would beat me if I
played him a match we're gonna set it up
- Wow yep it's on the I didn't he might
be a favorite let's see where's my night
going Oh Michelle
where is it going oh my bishops also
hanging Wow maybe I could have taken
your night I just can't get out
everything's hanging good god what a bad
position
okay this is going this is not a good
position I mean it's pretty good but
it's not had better that better yeah I
have an active King very active I've had
better that's what she said Ben yeah
design after night d3 no I don't have to
resign yet I was going to musical okay
93 I definitely would every zine okay no
you're not made it Ben
now law I don't have to resign so that's
good Oh My Achin darienne game technique
of one legendary I'm worried good it's
good to worry okay how's my time no time
that's good I've got another ending yeah
it's your favorite how did I care not
rending unbelievable this is
unbelievable again love it so I avoided
losing again Wow I think so how did I do
it I know this back and forth stuff I
don't want to do that good there
I'm gonna lose my pawn now darn maybe I
don't know it it's terrible oh well the
truth hurts I might lose it see all the
way over here
that's pretty safe let's see I have a
chance go Ben go Ben so you could think
y'all the sort will exists this will be
another classic endgame
another classic this is the way it
engages this is a classic for the ages
that's what's going to happen the
classic end game for the ages let's see
this guy wants to discover something
discover America ok let's keep trying
it's a classic - keep trying I know this
isn't good yeah I thought it was easily
drawing and now all I need I need some
help from my good friend not easy don't
see I have more time that's good
you took yeah that way I know I think it
makes me that was too difficult to see
that was a move that wasn't good just
required a little bit of fun I didn't
see that that's too hard that was too
hard
good technique as usual good technique a
great technique man are we even yet
somehow what am i ahead Danny I don't
know ok I'm ahead
ok good so how much time do we have left
Danny in this but come on give Lee
evenly killing all of us right now but
yeah but what's that was a good game
what do you mean we played well
well it might not be the best chess but
hopefully hopefully hopefully you know
it's something I'm not even sure all the
mirrors is it something yeah how long do
we have Danny of this this this time
situation we've got we've got another
couple minutes of of three minutes oh
yeah okay let's try this well trying is
the first step to failure the rest of us
are all in case you guys feel the same
way just counting the seconds until this
is over
no you're doing doing great you've never
been so impressed no this is the feisty
much you see come on we're making it
close like you told us what's the
problem true that is true yeah I did
promise that you guys would have a much
closer match than Magnus versus we're
here to please yeah close but bad don't
know once this is the highest-quality
match today yeah well there's no other
matches today right Danny that's right I
felt I felt I feel a lot better thanks
for asking otherwise it wasn't some pure
this again you think I don't know I said
you know it's asking a lot it's out that
you think it's been a big success than a
treat don't know you guys are still
having at five thousand viewers though I
don't know why people are I mean you've
had your moments people it felt like
it's a little pg-13 but you guys are
human beings you can't you know you
can't hate each other the whole show we
hate you Danny yeah that's mutual and
that's where you and the chatter spawned
exactly yeah what what the hate flow
through us what the hate flow through
giving this guy sacking a lot of pawns
you know if I don't have needed I might
be okay maybe if I don't get mated his
hearts get nice here yeah I know but I'm
trying well you keep trying you keep
trying well by the way another crunch
match by the way Danny if you got any
okay if you were gonna do another one
who'd you have Donnie oh we've gotten
some requests for me and been teaming up
Team America versus Lawrence Trent and
Simon Williams really you will be back
what the hell
Lawrence Trent who's that I don't want
you back I don't know we could do a lot
of grudge matches but actually one of
the sponsors wants to do this regularly
one of the guys who donated this match
wants us to do it I wonder if we should
do a rollover system though we're the
winner of the winner of the deathmatch
automatically gets to play the next one
so you kind of play to you lose like
jeopardy
just cute game and then you get like
that you have to wait a year before you
can rematch so Simon if you lose this
match or Ben right now at anybody could
lose you'd have to wait a year to
rematch and he's trying harder than me
though that's not right he is I'm trying
hard I'm trying to lose but he's I'm
running out of gas Danny I can't lose so
much I'm where I'm getting tired I've
always wanted to talk to you about your
stamina exactly well it's a three-way
I'm not used to it right no come on is a
lot going on here that's it that's it of
the three - don't read one what happened
okay then somehow somehow someway you
managed to slightly right the ship so am
i plus three okay you were playing one
minute now because he challenged me
three - so I shouldn't accept ya don't
accept that yup so we've got another
half an hour of bullet ahead of us
five day break five days yeah we were
gonna we're gonna take a quick break
some of us can go shoot ourselves and
then come back yeah paid if you shoot
yourself luckily we don't have guns in
America Danny they don't have it nearly
enough just that was what they're used
to me you kicked them out of Detroit
they saw the way he played that's true
okay so we got a break here so I'll be
back you guys also won the same matchup
in the 1700s Simon so you're gonna have
to pull it together here if you want to
write very well-versed of the 17
don't insult them even more he knows
what a minute
need a miracle but we're safe alright so
okay well I'll be back in a minute
anyway yeah yeah well um we'll throw on
some BRB music the fans can sit here and
hang but just take a couple minutes we
don't want to lose our audience numbers
they're not they're here by mistake
clearly they got lost on the internet
nobody is purposely hanging hung around
for any of this crap yeah you're the one
I'm kidding I'm just trying to be the
negative host I don't know I don't know
what role I'm supposed to play half the
time Ben yep well we've done three ways
before I don't see what the issue is I
know it's not like just mine alright see
you later for some more roleplay alright
okay these guys are funny Ben is Ben is
actually even funnier in person
I know you're thinking is he is he
uglier in person no I'm kidding he's
funnier in person I will say that um I'm
gonna I'm just gonna sit here maybe I'll
play a bullet game while we're waiting
what do you guys think I'm a little
bored this has been really stupid these
guys suck at chess just kidding let's
play some bullet while you guys are
waiting come on who do I got 25 29 okay
here we go
this guy I get this guy I want that guy
the problem I have against the con is I
never play my opening right like ever
like ever ever like forever ever forever
ever miss Jackson I'm sorry miss Jackson
what's he gonna do what you gonna do
when they come for you that was a
terrible move by me
these guys chess is rubbing off on me I
think I'd beat both of them in a match
by the way I know people think I'm like
Danny you're just a weak I am how could
you even say that but these guys really
really suck so oh it's funny okay how am
I gonna checkmate this guy
something's nasty is about to happen
right here on b7 oh right a little bit
delicioso little break in between right
a little bell ringer get it get it let's
do it let's play again you want more of
this you Ted you want more of this I'm
here all day baby I'm here all day baby
don't forget to tip your waitress oh I
know you guys don't believe me I would
beat them I got a plus record against
Ben and I got a plus record against
Simon in chess rivals I mean these are
two of the weakest GM's on the planet
okay these are not you know and I've
been an IM long enough you know to bore
Gandhi right he couldn't fast long
enough as long as I've been an I am I
mean this is ridiculous
I'm a terrible chess player but I'm
better than these guys all right don't
get me wrong
oh you guys are here you guys want a
piece of this huh I see y'all I see
y'all in the chat you guys want to come
and get this let's do it
I see this guy in the chat that was a
weird little bug there classic chefs
calm
okay here we go
let's play a five let's put a pony on f6
let's bring a pony into d5 No let's put
a pony on e4 in a second yeah let's do
that let's do it
what's up Simon hello your rights are
you doing baby I think I'm doing all
right but I have to say like one thing I
found quite difficult I'm used to sort
of streaming and talking about my own
games right when you've got when you got
the noise in your ear right it just
everything out the window so say
actually first for me to do that you
don't I sir
tough but okay as you can see but okay
one minute now
yeah by the way none of these let's see
no no none of these none of these fans
in the chat believed that I would crush
both of you in a match like this I mean
I've got an awesome record against being
Ben I own you and rival Simon
although stink when my buddy just said
that he agrees that I would smash both
of the owner match
I think the way we're playing I have to
say I probably make you favourite the
moment Simon's future ex-girlfriend is
texting me your wife your wife's not
texting me bang
no not yet not yet no yeah I think
you're safe though yeah so we've got
half a mile on it like it I got it I got
a beat this guy a bullet real quick what
are we playing here yeah you're playing
at 2200 yeah you're trash-talking how
great you are no I'm not trying to trash
like a great a.m. I'm not even playing
well against this guy I don't even know
what's going on right now that's that's
that's with Daniel enough of rivals
match if you want one I know Sokolov
wanted to play Nigel sure oh yeah I'm
skipping so he's a big one alright look
at this guy trying to come up with some
tricks oh he did come to all the point
one of us can I saw said with a chant
that shaders are even stupider than
Danny I can't I know they are Wow how
could they be that they work hard they
are not you have to get made it against
you don't look at the I'm not looking
the chat the check the chat something I
turned off I can't even look at it on my
computer the laptop part about the chair
the least pain you have some money too
let's take a few all right well that was
bad I don't know you won the three
minutes this is getting worse here we go
guys you ready you want a minute okay
we're ready okay so what would you will
have a match
we'll have a match we're all take on Ben
and Simon commentates will keep this
three-way going well I'll just switch
positions yeah this case which
Inquisition is important family man can
commentate me and Simon should go at it
Simon can commentate me and Ben can go
at it it's just gonna be I'm gonna cool
off after those comments
okay well the comments I still got
sandwich in my teeth this is
unprofessional as I've never been on
television right here yeah Danny with
those comments this is the most flaccid
anybody's ever been watching you it
really brought the best out of me guys
appreciate it yeah okay everybody again
if you are just by chance just joining
us let me remind you one more time what
we're doing this is a grudge match
apparently these two guys hate each
other
we think you know do they hate me more
than they hate each other that's for
sure
we've had some donations we got more
than that we got what is that I can't do
Matt that's about four thousand dollars
on the line but we've got more than this
going to charity from all of you
subscribers so if you want to increase
that fund some subscribe donate give us
some tips all money earned today at
twitch TV slash chess goes to charity so
let's do it let's increase the charity
here so these greedy guys can feel good
about what they're not if I lose this
one you know I'm gonna give a grand to
charity just the way I played it only
feels right you know so I know it does
feel right it does I mean the way I'm
playing oh you should do it as a dollar
you should go buy some of your own DVDs
and why maybe I should buy some lessons
of Ben ya know see we're playing bad but
out of the one minute in the one minute
portion then we're gonna play
no but seriously this is a close match
there's only three games separating you
I don't think anybody should be should
be going away from this channel just yet
Simon I are gonna leave it's been a lot
of fun
yeah you guys if you both want to retire
after this that might be the most
appropriate thing to do so it's like a
mom all right a man of this need a month
off let's go let's go team let's start
these guys up um go team go team and
it's charity stop yelling at us good
luck on this one minute portion we're
gonna both need it me more the one I'm
actually gonna I'm actually gonna pay
attention to the match nail I've been
zoning out for a while oh yeah cuz
because Simon made it close enough to
care I guess yeah I guess somebody has
to care let's play the most accurate way
still theory still fairy yeah I don't
know it's not theory well that must be
what happened yeah we're playing better
in the one minute that's good yeah yeah
that's right
you can change let's move people think
I'm being mean to you guys you guys
think I'm being mean deal you deserve it
you've never been mean anybody ever a
history of anything
people really think you're being mean
Wow no I know you
yeah me too this is uh this is the
famous game fine gold Williams very
famous yeah this is high-quality chess
here very famous yeah we put the high in
high quality yeah I could the high into
drinking this one puts the advice and
not pushing pawns around your Kings side
don't mean this he's like a walking
example he's the best you know let's see
let's let's it's let's do some
penetration in this three-way
oh there you know you go to penetrate
free why you gotta make this broad proud
then I trade away yeah the throughway
penetration isn't working so good
I think being I mean what's worse than
losing this is the idea being penetrated
by been there's bad things and that's
bad
things and bad truth truth will set you
free
that is sighs mad let's see I guess I'll
go here that's the book move that's
that's an idea it's a book move yeah
okay his favorite an endgame
nope let's see let's take this guy I'm
gonna end game yet right outside game
all right what's going on here
trash-talking with five seconds left
that's a good idea they slowed that's
the plan
c4 that's explosive how did he do it Wow
take this guy what's I don't know
doesn't look good the hope for the fans
was that you would have some new
material for this match Ben we have we
have no material same material this
isn't good this is not good let's see
why move okay neither one of us got
mated yet that's good not yet yeah no I
agree it's hard to imagine why yeah
exactly yeah I'm against it against
mating of all kind yeah exactly
okay I didn't hang my rook yet not yet
but I will that's lucky and there we go
he knew I was gonna hang my rook yeah
you see that it's one of those this aint
worse this is the worst thing that's
ever happened ever to anybody
am I gonna lose this Simon's technique
been lost on how did that happen
Wow you're playing let's just that's
quite shocking I was some good technique
I mean Simon's good at losing on time -
don't worry I'm very good
you'll find out soon time that wasn't
good darn I prefer not losing on time oh
well that's life in the big city I guess
- game lead right now for mr. Feingold
this was insane I used to be called
grandma Esther Feingold until this match
took place yep then and then I wasn't
there's anything still possible do you
think yeah except for me winning the
match come on bang leading you're
leading yeah still got his free way if I
had really whirring I'm something it's
not where you want it Simon no I got
something going on yeah watch some time
I was like why did the game end I was
very confused people think I'm right
we're still playing what's happening I
get needed one and I didn't notice oh
well the truth hurts I guess people want
the bong cloud Simon go Ben yeah I might
need to just have the bong after this to
be honest go then sure I'm going but go
somewhere pushing area I've heard of
area I don't know why I've heard of
Harry already hey Jerry
yeah I heard of you coming in I don't
have an e pawn well yeah it's a
three-way that's the only thing I know
how to do okay look I don't know what
I'm doing so I'm just gonna push all
right why not you can't make an illegal
move because it's not that kind of
choice I'm lucky then
okay let's no I don't want to do that
all right let's take
you're getting good positions I know
let's take yeah but so I'm gonna lose on
time enough forget about the clock
that's available terrible I guess here
cuz if you're legendary and getting
technique yep
legendary he is legend whoa
take this guy it was a bit suspicious
yeah everything everything is very
suspicious somehow Berta
yep I lose on time yet not yet okay
we're actually came in more time that's
quite cool yeah but I that sure shocked
me I can't believe I lost time time I
forgot about the clock completely
totally completely I didn't lose yet
okay good
nah it ain't okay about that but I
didn't lose yet no whoa I clicked the
wrong thing
I didn't lose on time yet okay all right
what's going on here we're both playing
for the loss in countdown once who wants
it more who wants to lose more let's see
16 15 I guess I do
come on Beth you can do it Ben
I'm not sure what something you can hang
everything I I can certainly do that
no I'm not gonna me Wow what's wrong
don't take a draw you take a draw you
walk it off I'm definitely not taking
the draw no I have not yet begun to lose
although I'm starting to lose but what
can I do what am i doing I might in
plain to sign it yeah okay whoops I was
gonna stop drawing and then you did you
tricked me
I tricked you first this is crazy this
is still theory you can do it it's not
sure what I mean we play great we're the
best
good chance yeah we're the best let's
see is this pawn too strong probably not
too strong for me probably yeah too
strong Hey go Ben do something I'm just
not sure what try to lose on time again
I'm remembering now why I've had myself
muted for most of match because I almost
blurted out when you blundered you're
Brooke for clinch e5 that Simon had
Knight age 5 yeah it's hard not to make
human and animal noises well you can't
do that that's not fair yeah yeah
perfect game huh my face is are you
gonna take the draw me down a piece
points for that
what for how hard this one is my store
head maybe maybe that was what is this I
did lose on time
okay I got better yeah but I think we'll
keep doing this deathmatch format where
the players commentate we won't always
you know build up the rivalry hype that
you guys hate each other's guts we'll
just let you guys play and talk about
chess yeah nobody came a lot of pressure
to warm Ben knows about pressure to
perform exactly especially these new
3-way systems you got going
we provide some pills for certain types
of pressure but not not the kinds of
been has been it's got a different kind
of but yeah I think it's better if we
don't you know force you guys to hate
each other's guts sure I think we did I
think we did briefly but then yeah but
then he played so well I learned all
this respect
yeah pretty much it was really good yeah
so I didn't get made it yet okay always
play Bishop f1 I mean I don't want to
but it's my rule so I guess I have to
okay
guess we can my king a little that's a
good idea
Fryman who won that last game by the way
was a draw draw you forgot I'm here I
was just ridiculous ma'am what that was
good game technique stop playing
we're playing great ridiculous from me
okay that now let's say I'm gonna take
the night now okay say two piece let me
now I'm gonna take it now you were piece
up yeah which you have some compensation
I just don't see it but you have it you
felt that clearly this is been this is a
mistake sakis nice with no compensation
this is his neck he's doing a good job
then yeah this is really bad
yeah this is I I have the piece of the
competition we can we can we can
generate we can generate some Billy Oh
Billy I [ __ ] honestly we have to
here comes the billy-oh last desperate
do it since
let's just keep trying why not such is
life
long as it's desperate is certainly -
forever that matters is just I'm a
desperate man in a desperate position if
I don't hang my queen I'm okay
but it's 50/50 I'll hang my queen yeah
you can leave sometime maybe
no I'm trying i forget about the clock i
Maldon confuse what that [ __ ] was that
he still has good
I'm sorry but that was [ __ ] appalling
that wasn't good this banner is sort of
I sort of a proof of that move that
helps your attack a lot Jesus look I'm
feeling I feel like this could be this
could be dangerous
yeah and I was clever yes what am I
doing here it looks like it's probably a
draw
oh I'll just play it on this one I'll
play on one more move yeah okay okay I
was trying to move I have to time we get
to quick been too quick Roger Goren play
see four oh I'll show you how it's done
okay that gives pregame wait here who's
where's my resign button okay okay
I'm the world's leading authority on
losing with this nobody's lost as much
as I have it's never happened Knight d2
I've never faced that it's probably good
I just never faced it all right let's
retreat like a Frenchman so okay
position it's 18 minutes how many games
can be game position I think one more
game is the limit I think that's it
my math isn't great one game max now
this guys coming again yeah me I didn't
hang my queen that's my specialty
you didn't well then well I didn't hang
my queen I can't ask for more than that
I mean I can ask but this is asking too
much son should be three it's like an
okay yeah that's no I know that's not
we're not good at that white lie is this
a normal game yeah exactly
it's pretty bad for black so that's good
I'm pulling the trigger and I should be
much worse okay Dave just punish me I've
had enough punishment always the way
they do I just give me more give me more
let's
this isn't good this guy's coming to get
me
okay d7 is safe it's not too safe yeah
what happened here this feels good and
now it's not
I guess just explain what happened okay
that was a good explanation we're
getting a bit of a remix of your voice
been meaning bad connection you sound
like a robot make sure none of your
peeps in the studio or like you know
downloading no there's there's a lot of
people here downloading any HD movies or
anything okay there's your johning
three-way movies they can understand
what's going on yeah okay here man I'm
not doing too well this isn't good well
the last movie things picked up a little
on the last month they picked up I see
Faust been too fast
don't you have more time oh no I do
makes a change their real trophy I don't
know here I don't know
takes let's see I'm pretty slow actually
okay never play off six probably the
losing move I don't think I can do it
I've got like ten seconds left yeah I
gotta play better so do I die it's too
late for me maybe this isn't good
nice let me not like my position but I'm
still complaining believe you're
complaining still my favorites no ball
ahead look at my readings I like that
reading it's me thoughtful oh yeah okay
I've never played you for this whole
match let's play it once
let's try Sicilian I can give up yeah so
we might as well go out dying as usual i
blundered upon and i can't believe what
i did the Bassman variation was saying
michael bears no never heard lucky I
can't hear you no it's giving you a
break Michael you thought listen no I
wouldn't win the match then that was my
only hope my words if
only yeah I mean it next time can we use
a mute button please please please Jesus
Ben I'm gonna have nightmares about you
tonight it's quite worrying first yeah
well you have your position
little little I'm playing like madness
except I'm gonna hang all my pieces the
next 10 rooms otherwise very magnets
like yeah I agree with H put a wrench
let's move Harry I don't know what's a
date so just do something Harry all that
matters all the way back okay let's
trade everything I can't hang my pieces
if they're traded yeah okay still theory
it's pretty boring it's very boring yeah
you spent nine seconds you claimed very
yeah you play much quicker now I'm an
old man or something confused always
play a four okay
I played a ch3 a four is the only other
thing we've I can think of there I don't
know
bang bang dude you smell many already
hominin Horan I don't like it I don't
like this position humming and hawing
all the way I don't like it humming and
whoring all the way to the bank Ben oh I
don't like it never play three I broke
my own rule now I'm gonna pay for it
let's see my turn
yes your time concrete always retreat
retreat you know I'm gonna retreat it
the hell itself people think I left you
because I'm sitting here being quiet to
live Danny yes we haven't hung any
pieces of skin this is the Harry Harry H
for go here no Harry go have to say
Danny I can't wait so this is over now
it's too much it's too much pain you
hanging on in there we thought you might
have a comeback in your Simon but it's
not looking like it No
you're not mathematically eliminated yet
you've got got some time if how much
time am I even the favorite this match
am I the favorites your sub knivert I'm
something everybody is somebody's
favorite that's true yeah well this is
an exciting gam riveting riveting stuff
I've been doing crazy twitches having
another network error everybody can
refresh if you can hear me sounds like
fun everybody's having a twitch there
twitchy now man let's see always retreat
so the longer this game goes the better
chances I have of the match is that what
you're saying yeah this isn't good he
traded bishops I was trying to avoid
that I guess I didn't do a good job okay
let's take his night all right my bishop
got out somehow nobody knows how yeah I
like those are migrating game check my
great endgame play no go Ben yeah you
can do it not sure what you can do but
you can do it it's done it story this is
the story it's the story of the
revolutionary what's going on why did
why did the things Rosen I think that's
not good I think it's had enough that
enough of us we broke the unit let's not
live that it says I will Auto resign in
12 Wow I'm the one just gonna die I
think something's happened there I think
she's had enough then it says I'm gonna
things have gone down this is enough I
wish I wish I'd have done that to shoot
myself and head but what's going on
Fanny is I think the service had enough
of us Danny I don't
what happened I'm still I'm still black
one it says black one I knew it so I'm
still on with with talking to you on the
internet but I couldn't lose darn no I
think you won okay it says black one it
says black one on my thing oh I don't
even know yeah you're right it didn't
say that too many realize now I have to
wait two minutes to go back in do you
know that's rematch there's only nine
minutes left in the match okay this is
slightly unfair Oh Connie I can't
actually login anyway so I think you got
it Bennett I lost this position yeah I
figured a my bandit Danny am I logged in
I don't know if I see you I'll just type
it again yeah you know let's see if you
know Danny I've actually got messy
saying I'm gonna wait two minutes to log
in now so yeah yeah I was logged in and
I still got forfeited I mean I just said
you had to wait two minutes yeah two
minutes to my clients everybody says I'm
here so I was logged in and I got I got
forfeited Simon you're looking in the
chat
Torin let me just okay let me just check
my internet is obviously working because
I'm speaking to you but okay two minutes
Ben well you get two minutes that lost I
suppose that's probably good enough for
you to take the match is shipping so I
bet if you enjoyed yourself oh yeah this
was the best part was Danny's commentary
yeah sure I I think the best part was
they're not looking at the chat I wasn't
able to get the chat up so and so it had
some nice base and I looked at the chair
the Brig that was probably mister it's a
very strange very strange match for sure
was very tough sorry where Danny you're
gonna take on Ben next time is that good
maybe we'll shorten the format I feel
like yeah I feel like people were sick
of you guys at 90 minutes yeah I think
so no I'm kidding nobody's sticking
anyway don't forget folks
all right good no no it was a lot of fun
actually and I think we will do it again
I think um I think before matter what
are we done
what are we done no we're not done you
guys can keep playing whatever you say
it was a lot of fun it's over
okay well look then I managed to get
back in now so I've put up a challenge
across gee how my internet is it says
you're the best know start start your
game guys rematch your game you want us
to you want us to peer you yeah yeah
except it didn't work
all right there then yeah come on guys
get a couple more e oh this is somebody
else challenging me that was a good
trick people do that a lot
very tricky chiki chiki chiki not
Pacific time
there you go Simon your move buddy
you're wiping your guys okay come on
we've got to finish a bit of that we got
seven minutes level with that forfeit
loss to men somehow you're only down by
three games Simon so Ben doesn't that
wasn't the fairest thing that was very
fair
I mean I think what it was anyway but I
think we will do it again with the dual
commentary deathmatch Laurence and I did
this a while ago but it wasn't like this
still theory knife is anything being
like this we've never had anything like
this no nothing like this has ever I
want to stream to divin and you know
what is going on there it's still theory
got some checks it you read a cold
position unusual theory what's still in
the book
you're a piece uptight Ben sacrifice
appease I guess I should have played
King g7 earlier oh well I can try not
finish on a high you know this isn't
good when you're Kings over here in a
woman again
it's not good probably not gonna defend
the best
well it'll be fun for everybody except
me
let's see my children yeah I'm doing
great
let's see something got no time getting
checkmated it's all good I'll take that
yeah that'll take advice I'll take the
attack yep you don't keep the attack
going as I take stuff yeah you take
stuff I gotta take something yeah this
is an interesting still some chances
yeah puts g4 and now he's winning Wow
oh well that was tough for me I was
doing well until I wasn't always play
Bishop f8 yeah okay now for my next
trick I'll go into the end game that's
that's only done three or four pawns
yeah waste a little bit of time only
down three or four pawns yeah okay yeah
okay one last game a draw just so you
guys know instead of a forfeit okay okay
that makes more sense
yeah even though I was losing horribly
so I guess minutes left and we're like
barely losing some miracle needed give 4
minutes and 20 seconds left
currently okay we have to go for a
camicazi attack Conran Shirazi oh that's
somebody else yeah a me guy
this is frying up man this is fun well
this is fun I hope it's fun for me but
it's fun long as it's fun sorry where's
the camicazi attack that's coming yeah
there's an annoying mate my wife told me
I was an annoying bad know what she
meant I know full well now I know full
well here we come here we go there you
go women no one
sound moves as often as you Simon and
then goes there we go there we go in
your point it's the last ditch attempt
Annie I need to I need to win ani to win
quick
now he's bailed out good idea good idea
I just thought I was checking you I
didn't see a [ __ ] could be six okay
I didn't realize can we keep the
camicazi against some how to do
something I've never been to head city a
lot of cars ahead let's see my turn
alright let's straighten these pawns out
straighten this right you have a lot of
pawns straighten this out you have a lot
of pawns here I can't believe I just
called you sir as well this is because
you know what has happened to me this
this is I don't know what's happened to
me this is this last hour will t if I
end up calling you sir then something is
clearly the first time I've been called
sir without being followed by you're
making a scene taking judgment here Ben
I think that was an original joke by you
actually I know darn it I'm gonna move
Harry soon where do you think they're
all coming yeah well I'm trying Harry
Eddie Darrell is it Darrell it's painful
is Derek Derek
David Derek the deapool derek has a name
too
they will have names these guys they all
have names Simon names as balls liver
career highlights yeah I lose on time
yet not yet okay after you got this one
okay I think with that one you thought I
told you pretty much put it away you
guys okay well we've got a finish for
Harry I agree let's finish with now
you're going too far just having a good
time you guys are bonding over Harry
things just like any we don't know how
the pieces we know how the pawns move
that's that's for sure check check plus
one oh my god the piece we play another
game Danny well actually you do have
time for one more because I don't have
to we can call the match right there I
think you guys it's asking for mercy
mercy
so who won the match I'm too tired you
know yes so Ben you won which means that
there's gonna be some extra money being
donated to your charity meaning your
chess club by some brand of donors dirty
been fine goal needs chess lessons a
very important charity yeah yeah Ben
Feingold nice I think there's a GoFundMe
for that actually I think I'm gonna get
him from Danny wrench yeah yeah the the
match is over this was a first time for
all of us
first there was a great last game that
was that was that was a high quality
like what does he chess that's one thing
that happened in this match was
high-quality chests I can say that ya
know knowing appropriates the love of my
competition what can I tell you I'll be
so happy to put some music on after this
point maze the stuff that nightmares
amazing lady died a couple days ago he
wouldn't want to see ya know this is uh
anyway well done Ben and I'll give you
that much interesting there were some
interesting games yeah there were a
couple couple in that yeah yeah we
played better than I expected
so the maybe not yeah I'm proud of both
you guys thanks I'm proud of you Danny
that's the longest three-way you ever
involves the longest that's the longest
time I've held my my bratty I'm proud
I'm proud of anyone who's stuck it out
yeah to the end so well done guys watch
this I've been drinking Danny as drug
they think spectators degree you guys do
the best give yourselves a hand yeah
no you guys are the best then no you're
the best well what we don't know let's
forget
that's cool so but people do do seem to
agree that the best game of the stream
was the horrible bullet game I play
where I drew yeah the this was a lot of
fun definitely different than what we
normally do I think we will do this
format again we're gonna find a way to
to bring more commentary together like
this you know Ben do you want to say
anything on behalf of your club or your
sponsors or anything before I go to my
students I hope you learned a lot from
this and that you get some more chess
lessons because you see how strong I am
and I really know how to move those hna
pawns I learned a lot today from Simon
Simon you let some of your students
watch this stream that's right I want to
thank chess calm and all the sponsors
and the buddies some of its gonna go to
charity and hopefully I could afford
some more chess lessons now I probably
have to get a better teacher because man
but yeah the truth hurts it's tough to
play three hours of blitzen bullet and
commentate all the time but we stuck it
out really as what we do is hard I ate a
big sandwich in the middle of the match
a big sandwich it was big bagel right in
my mouth but it was there a video of
that yeah it was I don't want to I don't
want to show you what it looked like but
felt good man anyway guys Simon we're
gonna let you lick your wounds yeah
Ben's we're gonna we're gonna let you go
glow to your members keep it down in
there members yeah very very busy but
seriously that you guys are both great
we all know you're both better than me
so it's easy for me to poke fun yet
somehow we all know I would beat you in
a match it's a weird thing to know that
you're better but it's kind of like
wrestling with your older brother no
matter what he's stronger right when you
guys play me at chess I just went all
the time do you want to play right now
Ben you can play I know that as much as
I love the American accent Jesus on
either break now I'm sure it's the same
English just sleep like a green minister
yeah I could listen to you talk Simon
England one
on a Harry Harry Kane goal in the 94th
minute by the way Simon okay there's
some something good something had
happened today good stuff
all right we'll cheers everyone for
arranging it as well thank you for the
sponsors and obviously yeah maybe a bit
more energy next time someone else does
it as well a bit of a different format
because I suppose normally I'm used to
just speaking or doing it with someone
but that's one way to just get me out of
the show next time we'll have two people
commentate I don't think I need to be
the middleman I mean a three-way there's
always someone taken the the bad end of
things you know and I feel like I got
the I got the worst end of this whole
you get worse than us did you get worse
than me Donnie I find out really hard to
the mill I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure I
got the worst there but anyway no thanks
everyone for watching as well hopefully
it was a bit of fun and then good luck
in the future for dinner and go Hotspurs
they have heart yeah all right Cheers hi
guys okay